salut
j'espère que tu vas bien donc
aujourd'hui tu es notre invité alors
invité on va dire un mystère ça faisait
déjà quasiment 10 jours que qu'on disait
qu'on avait une invitée surprise sur la
chaîne c'est comme faire donc je suis
content de t'inviter ici aujourd'hui
donc tu étais venu derrière remplacer je
sais plus qui c'était je crois que
c'était Mathieu cornet qui était parti
un peu plus tôt
comment
salut à tous famille que j'ai remplacé
après tout le monde
[Rires]
un petit peu donc les gens t'ont un
petit peu un petit peu remarqué mais du
coup donc là aujourd'hui pour toute la
ronde a priori avec moi et on va
commander du coup cette dixième ronde
qui s'annonce pas le pitante
donc du coup on va vous montrer un petit
peu les apparements du jour voir un
petit peu les chocs donc Fatou elle sera
en commentaire malheureusement je joue
pas
donc on aura so Wesley avec le blanc
contre
Ding avec les Noirs
anus qui est hyper hyper chaud qui est
le joueur local donc franchement il a
tout approuvé ici soy il est quand même
numéro enfin il est 3e pour la science
au classement donc il a les blancs donc
peut-être que sauve va essayer de
d'aller chercher Guiri en tout cas on va
voir un peu ce qui ce qui peut se passer
dans ce cette partie
sinon on aura aussi Abdou du coup
qui va jouer contre dingleren donc Abdou
ben c'est le gros leader du tournoi qui
a fait nullier un peu en souffrant mais
qui a fait nu contre Kemer qui va jouer
entre Ding qui est qui est
qui a un peu en difficulté il fait un
très mauvais tournoi dim qui va
participer au championnat du monde
d'échec le match contre nepo dans
quelques mois et demi qui fait un peu
une mauvaise prestation donc on va voir
si Ding assis abdos avec le lent peut
mettre la pression pour remporter la
partie et creuser l'écart d'avance qu'il
a sur gris quand je tournoi après on
aura du coup avant de Forest à quelle
heure donc c'est bon un jour allemand
peut-être pour toi Fatou
qui remonte au classement
ouais donc ça fait quasiment deux
parties quasiment d'affilée qui presque
gagnent un contreding et contre Abdou
très longtemps
il a envie de bien faire en tout cas et
mais on voit que souvent il craque sur
la fin il arrive pas à terminer les
parties donc ça trois quatre très dur
très certainement
ouais
c'est ça peut-être bon en tout cas en
tout cas c'est pas à cause du fait que
tu sois allemand tout c'est sûrement pas
du coup donc il aura les noirs du coup
on va sans caméra qu'on trouve en forest
on ne forest c'est encore un jeune local
qui a gagné l'édition il y a deux ans
qui est un genre très créatif aussi donc
on peut s'entendre une partie assez
sympa
rapport contrarunia donc rapport qui a
fait une très très grosse partie hier
contre contre iRig ASI qui aura les
blancs contre Aronian voir ce qui se
passe car voilà contre irigazie du coup
donc erwana qui aussi un auteur d'un
mont tournoi qui va essayer de mettre la
pression sur un qui n'est pas vraiment
en forme là on a le le choc de chez naï
avec Google
qui se joue donc même génération
peut-être un an de plus pour pour Prague
mais les deux joueurs indiens qui se
connaissent très très bien qui sont très
bon très bons amis qui vont se jouer du
coup lors de ce 30 10 et du coup
dernière table on a parram qui est pas
bien contre
manuscardsen qui vient de rapporter deux
parties d'affilée hier elle a fait nul
avec les Blancs contre gouquettes mais
du coup il y a encore des appareils non
un peu en sa faveur et peut-être qu'il
va réussir à remonter dans le classement
aussi donc avec Kevin on avait des paris
d'ailleurs sur le fait qu'il allait
revenir faire un faire un
un podium on va voir un petit peu ce qui
se passe alors on va vous remettre les
caméras la partie ont commencé
on va vous montrer un petit peu tout ce
qui se passe voilà
Fatou pour ceux qui ne la connaissent
pas c'est Fatou donc pas tout modo qui
est présente sur la majorité des
streams français stream d'échec qui est
modo de partout c'est la grande chef des
modaux et voyez dans les Schtroumpfs il
y a le Grand Schtroumpf et là tu as la
grande Fatou c'est un peu pareil en fait
et donc du coup Fatou qui qui va
m'accompagner pendant toute cette
après-midi
donc si bien sûr le stream veut bien
marcher la caméra qui saute hier on a eu
des gros problèmes de jamescom mais au
final ça a fini par par marché donc là
on a du coup une partie ici entre Abdou
et Ding donc c'est une Espagnole
viennoise avec Berlin pardon Berlin avec
cavalier prend un quart donc Berlin
c'est un petit peu pour toi aussi
peut-être pas tout
comme ça dès qu'un Allemand quelque part
ça va être ta faute alors cabane du coup
donc c'est quand même des lignes
berlinoises en fait ou si tu veux
les Noirs joue très solides et les
blancs en fait dans sa position jouent
plutôt qu'en deux résultats parce que
niveau structurel c'est un peu une sorte
de française enfin structure française
d'échanges avec des 4 dessins ou un peu
ou un peu des fois le pétrole on risque
d'avoir un foie F6 qui va arriver pour
pour parler des principes d'ouverture
c'est la partie parfaite pour parler des
principes d'ouverture oui c'est clair
donc quels sont d'ailleurs les principes
à respecter dans l'ouverture Fatou
est-ce que tu peux nous faire une petite
masterclass là-dessus
on va bien sûr mais bon je pense que le
chat connaît par cœur les trois
principes d'ouverture
bonjour à tous d'ailleurs
alors dis-nous que je suis pas sûr qu'il
respecte toujours quand il joue en
Bullet alors est-ce que tu peux
éventuellement nous les rappeler s'il te
plaît juste pour tes Vermont après le
reste le reste censé quand même
connaître centre développement rock je
vois c'est écrit juste pour tes
virements effectivement alors le centre
oui contrôle du centre on cherche à
contrôler donc avec souvent on met un
pion au centre et après le développement
des pièces on trouve aussi le centre
parfois deux pions au centre parfois
plus mais c'est un peu plus rare
développement ouais on développe les
pièces dans l'ordre les pièces mineures
d'abord cavaliers et fous normalement et
après des tours qu'on ramène vers le
centre
un peu comme ça a été fait là d'une
manière précipitée et rock
je leur ai dit autrement c'est à dire
mettre le roi à l'abri mais
effectivement souvent pour le mettre à
l'abri au rock voilà
cette partie bah après c'est une partie
théorique en espagnol voyez ou en fait
et ben on joue deux fois ici la même
pièce dans l'ouverture donc généralement
vous êtes dans les ouvertures on joue
vraiment une pièce parcours c'est
vraiment une course développement au
début voilà c'est un peu différent là
c'est une variante qui est qui est
connue qui est qui est
très théorique donc là du coup on
ressort un peu les principes et en fait
plus on connaît de choses plus on est
fort généralement plus et ben on peut
sortir un peu de tous ces principes qui
sont connus
si vous n'avez voilà si vous n'avez pas
trop de connaissances évitez de trop
trop partir dans votre truc parce que ça
peut mal se passer par contre si vous
connaissez bien les choses il y a pas de
souci
donc tout Rouen cavalier 6 vous voyez
trois fois que Cavalier rouge
et le fou qui revient en arrière enfin
c'est un peu bizarre mais bon c'est une
vente théorique et au final ici donc on
avait dit donc on va voir foi F6 tours
et on va voir sur mon cavalier F5 ici et
celui de d'un coup comme dessin qu'avec
les noirs et c'est une structure un
petit peu comme une
défense russe donc
Petrov
ce qui se passe aussi ici dans cette
position c'est que Abdou elle est blanc
contre
le numéro de mondial Abdou a un demi
point d'avance sur sur girit en ce
tournoi et un point d'avance sur tous
les autres
je pense pas qu'à Abdou enfin je sais
pas en fait on va voir mais il est
possible comme doux est une idée dans
l'ouverture et qui va y mettre la
pression ou peut-être juste il va avoir
une position je veux tranquille et
essayer de conserver son avance
dans ce championnat donc peut-être faire
une petite nulle un peu
[Musique]
ok on va faire des paris je pense si tu
veux prendre des paris et moi et tu sais
que je suis je suis ton homme
[Rires]
jamais à Paris
je propose lui d'abord dans le chat qui
qui
je pense c'est une partie tu as beaucoup
aimé celle-là donc reste attentif sur le
chat c'est une partie qui va te plaire
je pense
c'est la dernière ligne droite il est
bien
et moins
moins de confort dans ce dans ce tournoi
donc
en fait moi je pensais que Abdou vu
qu'il est en confiance qu'il joue bien
et que Ding est pas forcément en
confiance qui joue mal même si Ben les
joueurs enfin abdouk intenses moins fort
que Ling dans l'absolu et ben dans le
tournoi c'est pas du tout ce qui montre
et
du coup vu le choix d'ouverture et ben
il nous fait un peu mentir parce que
j'aurais pensé qu'il allait essayer de
jouer plus
pour enfin l'ouverture un peu plus
Sharpe quoi un peu plus
[Musique]
mais bon on va voir peut-être que ils
vont me faire mentir et qu'ils vont
faire autre chose
alors surtout un petit tour
des stades donc on a so guéri donc ces
joueurs qui sont joués
on sait pas combien de fois peut-être
pas dire une centaine de fois mais
peut-être pas loin et du coup ici
cavalier 3 des 5 G3 donc on commence par
un début Réty pour le blanc
pour ensuite le C4
et des quatre et transposer une sorte de
catalane avec des Français 4
d'un assis donc ça on a déjà vu cette
position il y avait une partie dans le
tournoi
je me suis un plus qui la jouer dans le
tournoi mais il y a une partie comme ça
je crois que c'était 45 blanc
carne blanc
je ne sais plus contre qui mais il y a
eu un carnet blanc foulard fougère
tous les cinq souvent c'est de
provoquer un petit âge 6 ici
avec les Noirs et des fois d'ailleurs
manger en F6 pour récupérer le centre
avec le cavalier C3 et le pion E4 il y a
plein d'idées théoriques donc on avait
dit ici c'est parti on l'avait un
commentaire avec Mathieu cornet
et du coup il disait que un des coups
possible avec avalé B6 il y avait aussi
A5 avec cavalier à 6 qui avait le BK
personne n'avait peut-être raté quelques
petites chances pratiques pour mettre la
pression
dans tous les cas
dans tous les cas il y a plusieurs
pressions plusieurs possibilités donc là
par guéri donc c'est une autre ligne
donc là du coup on risque de voir
peut-être un coup arriver peut-être
comme comme cavalier 3 qui a l'air hyper
standard
salut Hélène comment vas-tu
c'était coucou Hélène
toujours dans cette varente de la
Vanoise qu'est-ce qui est meilleur
tournoi ou des quatre bon ça et je sais
pas trop te dire je pense que tout ce
jour tout se joue un petit peu
épiméménite mais ça dépend vraiment
mais ce tournoi c'est vrai que bon déjà
des quatre ça donne un peu
quoi c'est clair alors tout droit tu es
pas forcément obligé de 4 dans la partie
il y a eu qu'avec ces trois hier
j'imagine qu'il va avoir envie peut-être
un jour de jeter un cavalier dessin qui
voire plus tard si je t'écarte quoi donc
voilà moi je recommanderais de ne pas
forcément jouer la barrière noire parce
que c'est une ouverture qui est très
très solide un petit peu trop et en fait
donc c'est pas quel niveau tu as mais
j'imagine que si tu as pas 2700 €, tu
enfin c'était pas longtemps tu as pas de
1700 hello donc du coup
pour un joueur normal
amateur comme comme nous et ben je te
conseille de plutôt jouer aux échecs à
sortir des pièces et de jouer autre
chose que la berlinoise qui est hyper
hyper
égalisant quoi voilà c'est pas très
drôle
donc
des débuts un peu plus ouvert peut-être
je te conseille juste ça après l'ordre
de coups exactement dans la barreloise
je peux pas te la donner exactement mais
j'imagine que chaque coup à ses
avantages et ses inconvénients
ok si on va à
panne donc on a du coup cette ligne avec
fougère on va revenir depuis le début
des 4 des 5 on a gambidam avec eux 6
cavalier 7 3 cavalier F6 on a une prise
et fougée 5 donc ça c'est aussi fou le
cas qui existait 3 H 6 fois H4 rouge et
donc ok
souvent quand le fout par un peu vite on
peut avoir une dame B3 ici
le pion B7 est aussi le pion des 5 avec
des fois du faux point F6 donc qu'est-ce
qu'on joue ici avec les Blancs et tout
voir si on a un petit aide non pas nous
dire
qu'est-ce qu'on joue
c'est un peu bizarre j'ai l'impression
mais je veux pas me dire
la bibliothèque de toscom veut pas me
dire ce qu'on joue sur foget4 parce que
ça m'a l'air bizarre en fait dame B3 à
l'air fort
attaque B7
[Musique]
simplement
en fait il faut voir ce qui se passe
concrètement
parce que bon on pourrait éventuellement
sacrifier un sacrifier un pion moi je
pense aussi un coup comme cavalier c'est
si éventuellement tu sais avec du style
quand tu prends B7 que j'ai cavaler B4
par exemple t'embêter un petit peu
j'ai décidé de faire trop B8
mais je pense que sur cavalier C6 c'est
est-ce qu'il y avoir 6 et la prise en
dessin c'est ça qui me vient un peu
et du coup qu'elle va essayer c'est pas
forcément l'idée
et du coup d'un bet3 comment est-ce
qu'on va réagir
[Musique]
je vais je vais en même temps
ce que je vais faire
propose F3 mais F3 là c'est au noir de
jouer
ouais en fait sur MP3 mais c'est la
place de
MP3 qui propose
mais ce que je vais faire c'est que je
vais parce que là bon je connais pas du
tout la position donc je vais essayer de
vous aider un petit peu au max et je
regarde un petit peu voir ce qui s'est
passé pour voir si vraiment
s'il y a moyen de
c'est moi
c'est marqué juste en dessous moi donc
enchanté bien sûr
alors je sens je veux juste mettre à la
base online
6 fois sur ma base online
j'ai une mauvaise base je prends une
autre base peut-être
je vais essayer un truc mais en fait
j'ai 4 c'est une bonne nouveauté
et
du coup
oups
je triche un peu avec chaise basse à
côté mais je pense que c'est bien c'est
pour vous que je fais ça on s'instruit
un petit peu
pour éviter la prise du cavalier les
problèmes sur des
mais il faut encore régler le problème
de B7 après je pense ouais
ok
je suis parti là dessus
et j'ai personne de très fort d'ailleurs
le plus fort hello avec les Blancs c'est
un 2375 avec les Noirs c'est un 2275
donc
il faut G4 c'est un coup qui est assez
nouveau
les gens en fait je joue qu'elle valait
BD7 mais
[Musique]
ok alors du coup je peux pas manger ici
parce que si je mange là il y avait des
prends juste donc le pion il est libre
si je mange des 5 et qu'elle va les
prendre des 5 et si je mange là je vais
manger le four en H4 donc jusqu'à une
pièce et encore échec il faut faire
gaffe
non j'ai faux aussi si je défends fou je
suis bête avec Madame
du coup c'est bon et
dont je me lasse pas de manger le pion
et sur cavaler bien
en 7 il y aura cavalier prendre set donc
cavalier prend ici n'est pas possible et
sur d'un point B17 là il faut regarder
ce qui se passe parce que je peux avoir
du tourbé 8 de ton premier lieu déjà
profitant du fait que que le rat noir
soit encore bien développé ça a l'air
intéressant d'ailleurs pour trouver là
qui peut arriver et rapidement
un problème de développement chez les
Blancs pas sorti encore mes pièces ça
peut être un petit peu embêtant
c'est la grosse préparation
et puis on va sûrement jouer avec un
coup comme C5 rapidement un jouet actif
en tout cas c'est bien intéressant mais
c'est une idée qui n'a quasiment jamais
été joué là je suis dans la base online
je vois qu'il y a que six parties du
coup sur sur
[Musique]
fougère dans le B3 quoi incroyable
attention
et tout le monde joue dans mes trois
qui a la logique
et du coup toi tout ce qu'il veut c'est
F3
provoquer F3
mais du coup justement j'irai en
[Musique]
E6 et du coup je sais pas vraiment si
l'ambassade d'avoir joué F3 est-ce que
c'est rarement quelque chose qui est
qui est grave parce que souvent dans les
pollutions on joue pour 4
donc j'arrive pas à bain de j'imagine
qu'il va y avoir un C5 rapide pour pour
attaquer vite le centre tu vois
mais
[Musique]
ça a pas l'air
ça a pas l'air facile quoi et d'avoir
honte de d'Hélène bah ouais mais en fait
tu vois
genre c'est quoi ton truc c'est Dame B3
G5
déjà je peux voir ça déjà
premièrement et une fois que je fais ça
en fait quand tu fais ça j'ai ça aussi
en l'air
donc je suis tombé vite bon il y a ça en
l'air enfin il y a trop de trucs en
l'air en fait tu as peur de la maison
Hélène
c'est compliqué
j'aime pas
c'est quand même de la tour c'est
injuste
la fourchette et dès que tu tombes
non
un peu déçu je pensais que
je pensais qu'on se comprenait mieux que
ça
[Rires]
peut poser des coups
mais c'est pas avoir par les remarques
de tout
juste avec elle il faut que ce soit
piquant
extra fort voilà
donc
c'est bien
ensuite un rapport aérien
c'est du coup rapport qui ouf ok bon
c'est un peu la même vous allez voir
cette partie là qui je ne sais pas si
elle va durer un pilon à va durer
longtemps il y a encore eu cavalier
prend un 4 donc la fameuse
berlinoise qui est encore frappé donc
généralement dans ces positions ben on
joue souvent avec un petit Détroit avant
pour empêcher toutes ces lignes à base
de berlinoise etc et du coup petit rock
tout droit qui est 6 on mange et c'est
la même partie que cap de contreding
donc là il y a eu des quatre ici
et là on a une structure vraiment type
française échange sauf que
sauf que
bon c'est pas vraiment tu vois il y a un
cavalier qui fait un mois plutôt un M6
les dangers 7 c'est un peu bizarre mais
à structure c'est vraiment ça
en fait bah écoute
je sais pas trouver l'avantage ici pour
les blancs peut-être du coup de
l'avantage de la colonne E
mais après Dame des 7 tours
j'ai l'impression que les Noirs vont
liquider
assez rapidement en fait
les tours et les fous
je sais pas si on va réussir à avoir un
rapport qui va presser dans cette
position
j'ai envie de dire que on va avoir une
une nule assez rapide
dans l'autre j'aurais pu parier là je
sais pas
[Rires]
évidemment que tu signes toi alors mais
après d'un côté on peut un peu les
comprendre dans le sens que
bon ils sont à l'arrondi ils sont
fatigués
rapports et rognan ils sont mieux de
tableaux bon et
de gamer justement à force de faire que
des longues parties
lui il y a bien un moment où je pense
qu'il
devrait en finir une bien vite pour
aller se reposer un petit peu
de repos avant-hier un encore une demain
enfin ça va tu vois il y en a mais bon
je pense même à leur niveau même la
préparation tout et même les jours de
repos au bout d'un moment
c'est dans deux semaines dans deux
semaines tu fais un tournoi c'est quand
même long quoi
B5 des 6 à 4
quand c'est hyper classique tout ça
donc
généralement c'est plutôt le fou qu'on
va en mesure en B7
et le C3
H6 donc là c'est le jeu un peu normal on
risque de voir un cavalier F1 jouer qui
avait G3 et ce genre de de coût donc
vous savez qui peut défoncé alors E3
c'est une fois pour aller en dessin ou
F5 mes cavaliers G3 et D4 c'est c'est
ici assez standard tu vois
et pendant ce temps elle est noir voir
s'il y a un moment donné ils arrivent à
jouer vous aussi puis des cinq qui
serait une une rupture au centre assez
standard aussi
bon en tout cas c'est l'espagnol c'est
pas vraiment une berlinoise c'est
production qui joue un peu plus
Google Prague là par contre c'est une
partie qui est complètement folle
alors les deux joueurs se connaissent
très bien
et du coup ben en plus ils sont très
copains et à chaque fois qu'ils jouent
bah ils se mettent sur la gueule
donc la dernière fois qu'ils se sont
joués je sais plus à quel temps c'était
mais Prague avait battu ou cache alors
qu'il avait une position inférieure et
Google j'avais un peu craqué en direct
il avait perdu
un peu les pédales donc là du coup je
pense que ça va vouloir prendre sa
revanche cette partie
donc si c'est à 3 fois 7 E4 donc on
prend le centre
petit
là c'est vraiment un jeu sur le contrôle
je pense de la case aussi E5
parce qu'après les F3 je pense qu'on
voudrait peut-être un jour même je
découvre comme comme 5 c'est le chaussée
de cavalier pour avoir les pièces
ouvertes sur le roi blanc sur le Renoir
dans la 5 qui cloue le cavalier qui
attaque le pion 24 qui empêche le 5 etc
tous les deux
dommage 5 ça c'est bizarre quand même ce
petit blanc tu vois
la tour géant
[Musique]
intéressant même très intéressant j'aime
beaucoup l'idée
5 G4 donc
on va essayer toi donc oui oui oui bon
après ça c'est sûrement ils sont dans la
théorie ils ont pas
envoyé tout ça
n'importe comment
donc bon j'ai un c'est un coup qui est
quand même assez surprenant dans le sens
que ben tu aurais pu à la place vers ton
géant bah tu aurais pu mettre le four en
deux tu aurais pu ok tu peux sortir une
pièce enfin voilà mes courgettes du coup
clairement c'est clair que tu vas faire
G4
mais quand tu fais G4 il faut quand même
savoir que ton roi derrière il va être
en E1 et que tu as pas forcément
[Musique]
tu pourras pas forcément ok ni ils
mettent droit à l'abri quoi donc c'est
pas évident de prendre cette décision de
faire tourner un quoi en tout cas en
tout cas
et voilà
n'oubliez pas voilà
non c'est chaud et donc du coup
du coup ce qui s'est passé c'est que Ben
ton prochain c'est
c'est un coup qui qui est assez
intéressant et là du coup
avec un tour géant et sûrement un G4 qui
va arriver
réaction
au centre
et ça c'est
comment les petits principes à connaître
voilà faut retenir et ça du coup c'est
hyper logique de dessin du coup comme
ton roi va être simple là tu viens de me
donner l'info que tu feras pas le petit
rock que grand Rock sera difficile à
faire vu tout ce qui est ouvert autour
du roi bah du coup moi c'est logique je
vais ouvrir la position 4
et donc c'était l'idée de Google et là
jusqu'à là je m'en fous de ta vie
c'est un peu ça
[Musique]
donc après l'idée quand même de G4 il
savait qu'il avait donné un pion mais en
fait sur le terme mais il a la colonne
qui est ouvert et il pense avoir du jeu
sur sur la colonne et sur le roi noir
donc il y a eu ses premiers 5 on prend
un cavalle premier 5 donc qui est plus
en F6 contre le plus
fou c'est ça qui attaque F2 et dame de
[Rires]
ok alors expliquons un peu ce qui se
passe tactiquement est-ce que tu peux
nous dire Fatou ce qui se passe sur de
base que vous prenez F2 ça m'a l'air
quand même assez intéressant j'ai envie
de dire que on gagne quasiment une tour
que se passe-t-il Fatou sur faut prendre
F2
salut à tous bien sûr
c'est fait pour être
donc
dans F2 ici et sur
et sur du coup
F2 que se passe-t-il
quand même
que je peux que se passe-t-il du coup
tout le monde de chercher
c'est très bien
la dame contre un fou
pour après gagner une dame vous voyez un
grâce à la tour géant encore une fois et
ben on gagne une dame
cadeau
et
du coup ici
fou F2 d'un point F2 donc fourchette
donc en gros il faut prendre F2 serait
un gros une grosse faute un gros blender
de la part de Prague pas été joué ici il
y a eu le coup F5 alors moi j'aime
énormément la position de Prague je sais
pas ce que tu en penses
mais j'ai l'impression que comment
on a peur on a peur avec les Blancs
là n'importe qui ne veut pas jouer à la
place des blancs
il y a des pièces en l'air il y a des
alignements de partout il y a un rose au
centre et une position qui s'ouvre ça
[Musique]
c'est un peu chaotique c'est
ultra chaud lui c'est ce qui fait mais
on donne les blancs à
la majorité d'entre nous l'immense
majorité d'entre nous
ça fait très très peur
si tu connais pas la position je pense
que
on perd tous dans les prochains coca
parce que c'est hyper compliqué mais
après bon Google je suis il joue ça il
doit savoir à peu près ce qu'il fait
mais en tout cas c'est une partie c'est
une partie hyper chaude et très créative
de joie et Google quand même des idées
donc je pense pas qu'ils se sont arrêtés
là dans
ces trucs genre peut-être dans ces
quatre cinq coups
mais en fait il faut voir ce qui se
passe parce que c'est pas la si débile
tu vois genre
je sais pas trop où
en fait c'est juste ça il va bouger je
suis très bien quoi
mais c'est vrai j'attaque le fou et que
je me suis aussi une découverte qui peut
manger la dame mais on voit en fait que
c'est c'est chaud quoi comment je
défends les feux 3 c'est moche là tu vas
manger là à manger là ton jeu en fait la
pollution a l'air complètement
la visuellement
merci
si tu me demandes d'évaluer la pollution
j'ai envie de dire que les noirs sont
sont gagnants quoi ah oui si on n'a pas
la barre là
imaginons c'est une partie de Fatou que
je vais commenter je vais dire n'importe
quoi avec les blancs
en fait bah oui ça a l'air d'être
bizarre mais mais je peux pas croire que
Google perd dans au bout de 10 coups
comme ça avec les Blancs donc il y a
sûrement des des complications alors je
sais pas encore comment peut-être du
coup
parce que lui
il a forcément tout préparé
il réfléchit quand même il réfléchit
quand même
et en tout cas PRAG qui a joué assez
vite aussi les deux joueurs sont on
commence avec une heure 40 on a une
heure 27 contre 1h31 donc rentrer
là-dedans avec si peu de temps
assez chaud mais après tu vois les Noirs
ils sont en mode allé quoi les Noirs ils
ont tous les fesses actives avantage de
développement j'ai roquet j'attaque ici
donc
le roi blanc il va jamais être il va
jamais être en sécurité
il se croit en Bullet ben ouais
franchement c'est une position
et comment je défends
au juste là
je peux pas venir faire
et
je te dis que si tu bouffes là je prends
et la fin je prends la tête c'est le
coup
j'ai un peu du mal à croire tout ça mais
regardez j'ai vraiment envie
voilà j'ose pas contente mais regardez
pas la jauge s'il vous plaît
l'idée c'est que je fais ça ça
et en fait tu vas où
parce que quand tu vas la bouger
j'imagine sur casse blanche je pense que
moi je me laisse quand même d'un échec
et par exemple juste pour vous montrer
sur ça par exemple bah j'ai échec d'un
point fou prend échec et ça fait peur
quand même non j'ai du cavalier F7 j'ai
des trucs ça a pas l'air simple
très brillant et là j'ai presque un
thème de Cava et Jessie de trucs
tu sens qu'il peut y avoir des choses
mais qu'il y a rien quoi ça je veux bien
qu'on la joue je prends les noirs et
blanc et puis
et puis on essaie
[Rires]
non mais c'est chaud et du coup on peut
imaginer peut-être des lignes où il peut
y avoir des trucs comme ça avec un
sacrifice de ton projet 4 qui peut être
très très bien être thématique mais bon
c'est c'est
hyper compliqué
il y a un côté très marrant c'est que
cette partie elle a l'air
débutant en fait ça fait ça fait un peu
je te tends un piège et puis tu tombes
pas dedans et en fait je me retrouve mal
sentiment
j'ai un petit papier que je me fais tu
sais où je marque les caméras
pour le papier je sais que tu manges des
trucs bizarres en string mais petit
c'est bon
en fait j'ai des j'ai des vu que j'ai 17
caméras 18 et ben je marque à chaque
fois quelle caméra avec qui comme ça
après quand je navigue entre mes entre
mes scènes c'est très facile pour moi de
vite savoir ce que je fais et où je vais
j'ai une question en fonction de quoi
sont faites les tables
que se passe-t-il
c'est pas grave
technologie
[Rires]
les caméras en fait non les tables vu
que c'est un droit tout rondes je sais
pas trop comment ça a commencé c'est
j'ai l'impression que c'est aléatoire
mais du coup je pense qu'il y a quand
même un sens quelque part
donc tu vois je sais pas trop
alors 2 pour l'instant je vais être
gentil avec vous je vais mettre la
caméra la cam numéro 2
parce qu'en vrai
hop là la grosse partie du jour en vrai
mince cette partie elle me elle
m'intéresse c'est deux anciens enfin
kanwa ils ont joué avec nous en Top 12
dans les deux
et franchement
avec nous
et c'était marrant ils avaient très à 14
ans
ils avaient 2550 tous les deux
et il jouait en haut contre l'effort dès
que j'entendais un mot enfin un nom
genre on joue on joue pas les bacros les
frais Scénic comme des fous ils veulent
tous les jouets
et nous on voulait absolument pas nous
on voulait se cacher
c'est génial
quand on est jeune on est motivé comme
ça
je suis en train de rechercher mes
caméras
c'est hyper compliqué
bienvenue bonjour à tous
nul non sérieux ouais bon
c'était assez non mais en fait en vrai
c'était
plausible
mon petit truc là
et
je suis mon tour j'en ai pour à peu près
une minute trente
même pas
même pas même pas
je pense qu'ils sont ils sont sûrement
écrit avant on fait nul OK
tu vois la partie je vous avais dit que
ça allait faire annuler très rapidement
voilà un petit sacrifice de tour
pour faire une belle fourchette mais bon
ça ça a tout fermé ok nul mais bon ok ça
fait une de moins
par rapport à notre petit tour on a
oublié qu'on n'a pas oublié mais on n'a
pas vu encore la partie de la partie de
ventes forest contre contre ton copain
c'est pour ça que je voyais pas
trop
et du coup
si c'est neuf voilà en fait ce que j'ai
fait ça sans faire exprès j'ai supprimé
de caméra voilà
il faut que je la retrouve
et je supprime un peu l'endroit il faut
pas supprimer donc c'est interdit de
supprimer
alors 6 du coup qui me manque
[Musique]
récupérer la tour
sûrement le faire plus tard
mais
le problème sur m2 c'est pour ça que les
plus loin sur la partie avant
la merveilleuse partie
mais tu verras après pour un problème
technique
parce que je sais pas ce que tu as fait
il est en train d'être réglé mon
problème technique t'inquiète pas
bientôt
si vite on sait très bien que c'est pas
c'est pas un hasard
mais bon
je sais pas
je sais pas ce qu'on peut dire dans ce
cas là
le fait de faire nul
c'est pas faire plaisir de semaine
je comprends que c'est pas bien que
c'est pas forcément faire plein ni quoi
que ce soit mais au final ben c'est un
peu les contrecoups tu vois certainement
et moi je suis pas du tout en train de
justifier j'aime pas ça mais
voilà je te comprends on peut expliquer
ouais sans justifier et expliquer
voilà ils sont très copains ils sont
fatigués ils veulent se reposer enfin
voilà
[Musique]
c'est ça
quand même c'était genre
30 coups et 3 heures de jeu
trois heures de jeu je crois ce que
j'avais lu
sinon les joueurs s'exposaient à
peut-être ne plus être invité
du coup là
je sais pas quoi dire
j'ai résolu mes problèmes juste checker
un truc là je suis en train de terminer
ça
je crois que ce n'est pas tout à fait 3
heures
je crois aussi
je remplace les caméras que j'ai sans
faire exprès
supprimer
on va répéter trois fois c'est nul mais
bon
souvent dans les tournois de toute
manière il y a au moins au moins par
exemple jouer 20 coups
ça tu peux pas empêcher de voir
[Musique]
il dit risque de plus être invité ça
empêche pas de faire nul mais bon ça
peut ça peut
c'est pas un arrangement pour un prix ou
quoi que ce soit c'est juste que les
mecs
ok donc moi je suis bon là je suis prêt
à tout
j'accepte
[Musique]
pour ça que je t'ai invité aussi
ah oui c'est pour pouvoir rejeter la
faute à chaque fois sur toi
du coup
[Musique]
alors qu'est-ce qu'on disait ici c'est
une espagnole du coup c'est ça
petit retour un tag c'est ultra
classique C5 je crois que c'est 6 H 6 à
4B 4 OK
donc là qu'est-ce qu'on peut dire ici
pour les blancs B4 de jouer le football
pourrait presque revenir enfin revenir
pour l'instant et en fait pour lutter
contre le fou moi je verrai bien un
petit cavalier C4 peut-être
un petit peu sur les cases central
voir un peu ce qui est possible de faire
ici
mais sur cavalier F1 j'ai trois restes
toujours
une idée un peu universelle ici
mais bon ok position assez standard
assez tranquille tac je vais voir ce qui
s'est passé un petit peu on voit
abduding que je pense qu'ils vont
bientôt faire nul aussi
je pense qu'aujourd'hui il savait que
c'est Fatou qu'elle est commenté ils
sont fermés
qui se battent comme des lions pour pour
impressionner la belle Fatou
du coup alors parce que la partie de
abdoulding je peux vous montrer
rapidement c'était la même ligne que
[Musique]
qui a joué du coup à rognan contre
contre rapport donc il y a eu G5 il y a
eu ici des 4 donc les pièces s'échangent
pour prendre donc elle est bien là et là
on a une position assez symétrique on
peut y jouer des 5 encore plus de 5 ça
va vraiment dire ok on échange tout quoi
donc là on peut s'attendre
un et il va falloir quoi et mais bon
qu'est-ce que tu veux dire
tu as bien pronostiqué
qu'on a vu dès qu'on a vu dès qu'on a vu
le début de enfin d'ouverture
on a compris que ça allait sûrement
faire nul très vite
avec chez Abdou et chez Carval et chez
après pour abdouche comprends parce que
il gère son tournoi il est un il est
leader et joue contre contre le numéro
de mondial il y a pas forcément envie de
prendre des risques donc je comprends tu
vois c'est pas qu'il est pas faire play
c'est pas qu'il a pas envie de jouer
c'est qui gère son tournoi je pense que
je dois plus comme ça en tout cas avec
avec
donc à voir
il va lui arracher la main
ça j'en suis complètement persuadé
c'est pour faire du comme ça j'aurais pu
faire le tour
en fait tu aurais pu proposer ce qu'ils
ont accepté je ne sais pas
mais oui mais
qu'aujourd'hui
il faut qu'on contrôle tous le règlement
on finit tous rapidement il y a un
problème il se dit ok aujourd'hui on
fait tous nuls comme signe de
protestation
c'est très drôle comme pour les stations
ok donc
le fou 4 et le foot c'est une sorte de
clouage tu vois sympa en fait bon on va
pas manger de cavalier sinon normalement
c'est plutôt en fait on va attendre que
le cavalier bouge pour manger ici et
plus tard on va essayer de jouer avec E5
coups et 5 pour éliminer le pion central
donc
Aniche qui est ici peut essayer de
d'égaliser assez rapidement en position
peut-être un petit cahier des cinq aussi
qui peut être sympa genre
tout au centre
non mais c'est une blague
[Rires]
c'est bien sur une blague il y a pas de
protestation il y a pas de problème
enfin j'en sais rien moi je suppose au
courant de ce qui se passe là
le second degré ah c'est les retraites
c'est ça c'est des retraites chacun de
leur pays en Norvège la retraite ça
marche pas bien en Inde donc j'en parle
même pas et en Chine et puis surtout
pour ceux aussi aux États-Unis voilà
c'est c'est tous en même temps ils se
disent tiens comme ça il va nous
entendre je pense
c'est ça
se passe bien
mais sinon les autres ils ont tous
c'est comme ça donc là non on va avoir
sûrement
en tout cas c'est ça que ça va être un
coup qui va être joué très bientôt
oui je parle pour le nord en fait je
vois pas trop comment les blancs peuvent
gagner parce que en fait pour progresser
ici avec les lents il faut que tu
arrives à jouer un jour un pion au
centre
et donc là on peut imaginer un coup
comme cavalier 5 ou un coup comme
cavalier des deux
5 c'est pas forcément un bon coup parce
qu'en fait c'est un coup que j'aime pas
trop d'ailleurs je vais dire la vérité
et pourquoi parce qu'en fait on va
échanger tout change là et change la
échange là et en fait ton pion en 5 et
ben il bloque un petit peu ton fou t'en
fous des deux et j'ai l'impression
qu'ici les noirs n'ont absolument aucun
problème tu vois je peux menacer un
petit cavalier prend ses trois qui peut
complètement aplanir la position sur un
fou ici ben je peux jouer un beau
cavalier en B4 alors une belle case pour
le même des cinq enfin toutes mes pièces
jouent et sont bien placés donc en fait
je pense que ces échanges massifs
pas du tout les blancs moi j'aurais plus
d'un coup comme cavalier 2
pour échanger comme ça et peut-être
jouer pour E4 mais bon dans sa position
là et ben les Noirs ils vont peut-être
jouer le 5 eux-mêmes pour essayer de
changer un petit peu les pions tu vois
ou alors joue c'est 5 alors ces cinq je
suis un peu moins fan
pour plusieurs raisons la première c'est
que en jean c'est 5 le pion B6 il
devient un peu faible
il est un peu en arrière par rapport à
la structure alors qu'avant ça c'est
quand même plutôt cool
et en plus en 5 et ben je vais ouvrir le
beau fou d'occasion noir donc je suis
pas sûr que vraiment c'est soit quelque
chose de grave mais par principe j'aime
pas trop ouvrir ta pièce
pardon ça donne des cibles voilà en fait
le Fouju alors que le fou bah il est
pourri en jouant 5 j'ouvre c'est vrai
mais je garde ma structure ouverte et
puis bon bah j'ai comme idée plus tard
de venir aller manger ce fou et
puis voilà mais toi ici il y a pas le
but il y a pas de pion au centre ni pour
le blanc ni pour les Noirs c'était comme
à la base l'avantage des blancs d'avoir
un pion au centre donc ben si on fait le
ménage le milieu ça va s'égaliser quoi
donc je vois pas un gros combat entre so
et guéri pour le coup je vois pas un
gros combat à arriver j'ai l'impression
que les Noirs ont déjà réussi à
quasiment égaliser ici
intéressante à base d'un C8 d'un B7 pour
venir renforcer cette belle diagonale
blanche même un tour à 7 dans la 8 qui
peut aussi être possible
mais
[Musique]
non mais j'ai l'impression qu'ici les
noirs sont déjà bien guerrier mais bon
tu vois guérir les numéros 2 dans le
tournoi
Wesley et les numéros 3
donc ils sont bien placés est-ce que
vraiment saut va faire all-in pour
absolument dépasser guéri pas sûr les
joueurs qui se respectent beaucoup qui
ont déjà beaucoup joué ensemble je vois
moi je vois une petite nul ici
donc Abdou je vois une nul à une grande
nulle et
guéri je vois une petite nul
car c'est un saut donc il y avait eu
personne parram donc avis elle a fougère
qui était une quasi nouveauté ici
avec échec ok la période de B3 je pense
qu'il n'y aura pas de
clair et venir manger des sets il a pas
eu envie non plus pardon de jouer F3 ou
de jouer à un fou en cavalier en E2 il
s'est dit surement que ce fou était
mauvais que sur le long terme il aura un
problème donc il y a eu dans ma 4 c'est
6 faut dire trois et H3 pour virer ce
fou une fois qu'il a deux fois H5
qu'est-ce qu'on fait alors G4 ça m'a
l'air intéressant moi j'aime bien les
coups comme G4 comme ça
mais est-ce que vraiment c'est bien
je sais pas
j'ai quatre fougères 6 on va manger en
G6 et la structure elle est un peu
bizarre quand même chez les Noirs tu
vois il y a personne qui contrôle il y a
pas de pions en fait qui peuvent
contrôler 5 donc j'ai pas envie de
mettre un petit cabane dans le 5
mais j'imagine qu'il y a qu'un problème
sur
un développement le roi blanc qui est
ici petit rock ça va être difficile à
jouer vu que j'ai poussé les pions
devant le roi et quand rock ben je suis
quand même assez ouvert donc peut-être
que du coup Caracal il s'en fout il dit
que c'est compliqué que le roi blanc a
pas trop d'abris
pas simple
mais ça c'est bizarre parce que
généralement tu as pas envie de te faire
manger comme ça
et du coup la personne avec son pouget4
ça rend les idées un petit peu un peu
différente qui sortent un peu de
l'ordinaire quoi
et c'est aussi pour ça car
quoi donc ça il est capable de jouer de
jouer tout et n'importe quoi de jouer
plein de système et plein de nouvelles
idées et il comprend toutes les
positions quoi
et du coup H5
j'écarte il ne jouera pas je pense c'est
un peu tout match j'ai l'impression
peut-être qu'elle va aller au deux
deux pour venir sur une casse comme ça
et peut-être finir par croquer ici quoi
mais du coup cavalier U2
est-ce que les Noirs mangeant eux
est-ce que juste je garde mon foulard
mais est-ce que sur le long terme c'est
bien
toi tu serais tenté de prendre
ben en fait à la base se fout c'est le
mauvais fou de la position donc c'est
pas c'est pas un coup qui m'étonne plus
que ça quoi genre ce qui est assez
logique dans ces positions ce genre de
manger là
histoire de manger là et en fait tu vois
tu as une position assez solide ça c'est
typique de position
donc je me verrais plus une idée comme
ça
après je sais pas mais faut deux pour
moi c'est pas du tout un mauvais coup
enfin c'est pas du tout un coup à
exclure parce que toi tu prends les deux
soit tu te dis tu acceptes et tu dis bon
bah ok il faut calculer
cette position quoi et encore une fois
cette pollution pour moi elle est pas
claire quoi tu vois j'ai ça
j'en sais rien mais il faut calculer tu
vois mais c'est un truc qui
en fait avoir le pur en G6 de manière
générale ça peut être un problème j'ai
même dame chez eux par exemple tu vois
c'est pas simple
et du coup
soit il a vraiment une idée claire de ce
qu'il veut faire avec sa structure il va
laisser fouger 6 soit il va juste manger
en deux qui est juste ok je pense
mais en fait la différence entre en tout
Cassan et un autre c'est que peut-être
que un joueur solide aurait fait prendre
U2 et dire ok bah faut de cavaluer
donc il va sûrement essayer d'avoir la
position la plus déséquilibrée possible
pour essayer de gagner noir il veut
gagner donc
non non mais c'est intéressant
c'est la diagonale B1 H7 oui oui en plus
tout est ouvert donc il y a du plonger
ce qui est faible il y a la case blanche
qui sont faibles il y a là voilà donc en
fait tu sais pas trop si vraiment tu
veux manger aux deux ou deux ou faire
fouger 6 pour moi les deux coups ont
l'air ok mais fous
ça m'a l'air un peu bancal mais
mais bon
en tout cas il faut prendre
que c'est déjà OK
est-ce que tu veux qu'on retourne sur
notre belle partie qu'on avait entre nos
deux petits jeunes
chez eprague parce que c'est une partie
qui a l'air franchement
hyper intéressante
[Musique]
à la courbe elle a pas du tout aimé
alors
j'avais dit ça mais apparemment madame
essaie c'était pas forcément le meilleur
coup
de C4 est un coup voilà
[Musique]
ça peut
ça peut sembler douteux
la tour 2 oui c'est ça prend les classes
de toutes les pièces ça défonce depuis
un F2
mais je sais pas
S
peut-être que c'est juste débile ce que
j'ai proposé
ce que j'ai depuis un mois
parce que
aucun moyen de défendre au bout d'un
moment
ouais mais c'est pas une raison quoi
enfin
ça va pas
l'idée et de bouffer là bouffer là mais
bon ça marchera pas non plus hein
j'ai pensé non
on a regardé ça
on a regardé
tout à l'heure on a regardé avec Fatou
on a regardé tout reprend G4
ça et ça qui avait l'air pas mal parce
que je me place échec malheureusement en
fait j'ai rien quoi j'ai pas de tactique
ça dans tous les manuels ça marche
qu'avec les 6
mais malheureusement là ça marche pas
quoi
j'arrive pas à le faire marcher
il manque une petite pièce pour aller
mater
malheureusement
[Musique]
là c'est chaud
une tour ou une dame est-ce que tu veux
route ma cavalier encore trois cavaliers
pas mal aussi
je vais quand même demander à
l'ordinateur ce qu'il en pense parce que
c'est une position qui est déjà
complètement franchement c'est trop dur
quoi
que dit-il
F5 bien joué
bien joué
bien joué grand rock ah oui c'est
logique
lui
[Musique]
ou ça tu veux le mettre là
parce que
il a déjà il a déjà un rôle et c'est
surtout qu'on a on a d'autres priorités
avec les noirs
on a de l'attaque et on attaque où là en
l'occurrence on doit bouger la dame qui
l'a fait
mais c'est plus les blancs qui ont un
problème donc nous on a on a de quoi
continuer à être agressif pour le moment
avec les noirs
mais en fait la position est tellement
compliquée pour les blancs en fait
tellement les blancs se font attaquer
très vite regardez il y a un fou et un
cavalier qui attaqué F2 il y a un une
tension ensemble j'ai une tour qui
arrive ici rapidement le roi est encore
au centre en fait du coup tout ça montre
que elle aura blanc il est hyper en
danger et qu'il faut faire quelque chose
rapidement donc tactiquement on va
regarder les trucs avec un LG 5 avec
tourprange écart on regarder plein de
choses qui ne marchent pas
et
du coup cette tournure c'est un peu
c'est un peu passif alors que quand
rocke ici ça aurait pu être une
possibilité
mais bon on perd quand même des pions
mais sur pas me faire tout reprend là il
faut calculer
je peux voir ça marche parce que là si
je mange là il mange si je mange là il
mange là par contre je vais mettre un
coin intermédiaire comme kg 5 qui me
permet de récupérer la
mais ça reste compliqué mais il y a
quand même
du style en fait s'il joue par exemple
d'un point F2 non enfin
et après avoir cavalier le chèque et mat
c'est hyper chaud en fait
donc
[Musique]
de voir
on dirait pas mal très heureuse elle est
très heureuse non je vous promets en
plus c'est pas une blague
elle joue avec est tellement contente et
tellement qu'elle crie et elle pleure en
fait elle pleure mais mais
non
mais en fait l'idée c'est vraiment que
elle a une peluche c'était quelque chose
que sa peluche et ben elle est trop
contente et elle pleure elle pleure de
joie donc là je le sais voilà
mais
en plus Maria est parti là
faire des courses et toute seule à la
maison
bref donc tour G2 c'est un mauvais coup
parce que le courant qui était peut-être
plus
[Musique]
meilleur mettez le roi mettez le roi en
sécurité avec quincaillerie c'est ça
ouais
donc
c'est pas le cas donc là du coup on peut
essayer de
punir en ouvrant la position que se
passe-t-il si je mange juste 4
justement oui Arnaud c'est vrai que là
on l'a pas vu mais un peu par
déduction par l'élimination si tu veux
tu as trouvé sur F2 je peux
difficilement le défendre c'est vrai que
une fois que je Roque
et ben mon cavalier point F2 faut voir
faut calculer mais ça m'a l'air bizarre
ici
tu vois bon là les coups de l'ordi sont
absolument dur à comprendre quand même
mesdames B5 pour menacer le fou c'est 4
c'est c'est très fort
mais et surtout prenez le temps on a vu
la ligne c'était à Tours J4 pour manger
ici et avant de manger ici
si je mange là en fait je vais venir là
à tous défendre un petit peu et après je
vais venir manger le flou voilà et
d'ailleurs sur dame ici je mange là
c'est un point ici je fais chaque
et quand il bouge j'imagine une
découverte sur la dame et sur la tour
donc ça on l'a vu tout à l'heure
et du coup en fait quand rock et ben les
présents F2 ne marchaient pas du coup ça
permettait un petit peu quand même à mon
roi de se mettre à l'abri mais bon ça
enlève pas que plus tard sur le long
terme il y aura quand même des problèmes
sur F2 et ça a l'air compliqué
quel est le 5
aussi aussi mais tout à l'heure à leur
intéressante pour
pour
la noire quand même à la place cavaliers
qu'on l'a vu tout à l'heure ça ça
tout qui tombe en fait
tout qui tombe mais c'est pas étonnant
au final parce que quand on voit tout ça
et ben en fait on voit que
au final ce qui pose problème chez les
Blancs c'est le roi quoi
donc quand on voyait de roquer aux
échecs c'est important là on est au on
est au 16e coup les Blancs n'ont pas
encore Rocky et du coup ben c'est
quasiment fini en fait c'est quasiment
foutu déjà parce qu'il rentre pas
et donc du coup là ici sur ton G2
on peut imaginer elle se prend un 4 et
il y a un problème sur le cavalier
et puis
c'est pas trop le choix
parce que bon c'est pas
[Musique]
et là dans
avec les Blancs
et là maintenant Fatou on pourra
peut-être menacer notre joli petit match
comme vous voulez faire avant
on avait un petit Mac ici très très joli
et tu peux le faire en plus forcer
ça fait nul narco ouais ça fait une très
très vite bah pas l'avoir c'était une
nul à ranger enfin
du coup
j'ai deux
donc sur la prise là peut-être du coup
il faut défendre nos pièces là enfin la
cavalier peut-être d'un F5
je garde la prime là dessus
je garde ça
garde du E3 aussi qui peut être un
joueur arrivé pour tout ouvrir et mettre
la tour ici ça a l'air très très dur
franchement
j'ai beaucoup de mal à imaginer que
que les blancs vont sortir dans cette
partie
on y croyait parce qu'on se disait que
c'était préparé mais
pas tant que ça
le tour jet d'eau il nous dit que
peut-être que
peut-être que non la prépa est fini
après quand rock va trouver grand rock
quand même lis par déduction oui si tu
élimines tout si tu calcules toutes les
variantes mais bon nous on bouge les
pièces
si tu l'as pas si tu l'as pas vu avant
grand que tu as pas non mais après si
c'est dans les thèmes de la prépa tu
peux le trouver quoi
mais du coup
c'est peut-être juste
moi peut-être qu'il a dit tiens on va
rigoler on va faire tourner mais je
crois pas par là je pense quand même que
il y avait un truc plus ou moins qui
était connu de la parole parce que faire
tourner
quelque chose d'assez
c'est clair
ok alors du coup on va aller voir un peu
ce qui nous donne notre petit Abdou donc
je rappelle Abdou qui est
qui est quand même
en tête dans ce tournoi
je vais vous mettre au
my bad
petite caméra sur sur
cette partie là
il y a d'autres résultats par la
première nuit ou pas
en fait c'est une position sans risque
mais il peut jouer un peu quoi tu vois
même six ou D5 je crois
donc on peut se douter que la pollution
elle est égale qui se passe pas grand
chose et que ça risque de bientôt faire
un nul
mais
c'est quand même
moins
[Musique]
on va dire
que la partie par rapport à
une partie elle va faire mieux j'en suis
persuadé
tu veux comparer ou pas
de la salle
c'est possible c'est bon je viens
d'enlever merci Samy enfin tout à
l'heure j'ai fait une petite erreur
[Musique]
j'ai dû
j'ai dû recréer les caméras et du coup
le son est venu tout seul OK
ils ont des micro sur la table non c'est
les caméras en fait qui peuvent avoir
un micro comme même moi ma webcam elle
fait micro aussi
moins performante qu'un vrai micro pour
que j'utilise pas mais ça fait micro et
du coup en fait j'imagine que les
caméras qui sont utilisées dans la salle
et ben ils ont pas dû enlever le micro
qui était de base connectée dessus donc
voilà mais c'est tout quoi du coup des
fois oui c'est à moi je peux je peux
rendre silencieux le micro des caméras
de la salle de jeux
chez moi
c'est pas trop bruyant ça
je suis pas sur le live chez moi le live
il est muet
sinon je t'entendrai en double enfin
ah oui
nul
qui est important pour la suite oui en
fait
[Musique]
il a un demi point d'avance sur guéri un
point d'avance sur saw un point et demi
d'avance sur Carlson bon après cette
ronde il en reste trois a priori Abdou
s'il commence un peu à faire quelques
nuits et tout a priori tournoi il est
pour lui quoi tu vois donc je pense que
c'est pas bête pour lui c'est un même
stratégie de jouer plus solide et un peu
plus pour la nul pour gagner de l'argent
c'est quand même assez incroyable
donc là maintenant on passe dans une
phase de tournoi ou en fait et ben il va
essayer de jouer pour gagner une
tendance donc c'est une manière si tu
veux de pouvoir
gérer quoi simplement donc donc on va
voir en tout cas mais ça va bien petite
tenue ici entre digne
le micro fait des ondes c'est donc un
micro-ondes
en effet
c'est cette barrière mais
c'est un petit blanc oui parce que
j'essayais de
[Rires]
aujourd'hui ils ont pas trop envie de se
battre j'ai l'impression les joueurs
t'inquiète pas il y a bien qui va se
battre
qui va jouer 6 heures pour faire nul
pourquoi pas donc moi je vois une nulle
d'Abdou contre Ding je vois une nulle de
saut contre guéri
et il restera du coup
parram Carlson qui va je pense jouer car
washi qui
a l'air de jouer aussi
qui joue clairement contre Prague
et vente forest Kemer qui joue aussi
donc on va récupérer le pion donc il est
très souvent une réaction normale des
Noirs c'est de préparer des cinq pour
éliminer le centre et avoir une
pollution assez tu vois
symétrique avec les pions tu vois ici en
fait les blancs sont mieux au niveau de
la structure c'est le Pione S6 parce que
du coup il a un peu en arrière etc et en
bon espaces et du coup les Noirs vont
devoir jouer descends quand à un moment
donné pour échanger cette faiblesse
contre l'option E4 et tout changer quoi
donc après de manière générale les
blancs sont pas mal parce que du coup la
paire de fou quand même assez active
mais les Noirs aussi une fois que les
pions sont changés au centre ils vont
changer les pièces ils vont aussi
prendre position du sang quoi donc bon
position pour l'instant
[Musique]
donc on va en gros la partie qui est de
plus en savoir c'est
la plus intéressante c'est Google je
prends l'impression
on a
c'est la plus mouvementée mais celle de
nouveautés
ça joue un peu plus mais pas tant que
non plus
un peu plus nouveau un peu plus spécial
du coup il y a plus de chances que ça
que ça tourne plutôt que les parties
plus classiques qui ont déjà été joué
des dizaines de fois voir des milliers
non c'est clair
donc
je t'y pressing que le pion insiste qui
un jour pourrait peut-être une faiblesse
si on peut imaginer
donc il y a un petit pression pour le
blanc je pense sur le long terme
donc première question à ce qu'on mange
en dessin où est-ce qu'on juge pouvait
être
moi
garde un peu les pièces
puis toujours les sortes de trouver des
faiblesses des cibles
et puis là on en aurait une
faute
sur le long terme je peux pousser ouvrir
un peu la position ouvrir mes pièces
quoi voyez après faut B3 on met vraiment
un fou sur une sur une belle diagonale
et
donc intéressant quoi
[Musique]
un petit truc
de
n'a pas
abouti hier
et il aboutit pas forcément
hier il était hier il était
il était
quasiment gagnant contre
il a poussé franchement un Baudou la
trouver enfin il se défendu mais c'est
ouf
cette défense dans la finale ça montre
quand même une grande force de caractère
d'Abdou c'est monstrueux cette partie je
leur ai perdu 10 fois
[Musique]
et contre par contre contre Ding là par
contre c'était un gain plus tôt
plutôt écrasant enfin c'était plus
facile tu vois il a un coup
[Musique]
à deux point d'interrogation ouais non
il avait fait une mauvaise finale en
fait il aurait pu il aurait pu essayer
de gagner plusieurs fois mais
en fait j'ai l'impression que dans ce
tournoi il est vraiment en manque de
confiance qui meurt parce que il a raté
pas mal de gains il craque en fait on
est position ou un joueur à 2700 euros
donc
si moi je craque position bah ok normal
niveau mais c'est quand c'est un 2700
qui craque dans ses positions là c'est
un peu plus surprenant tu vois
700 € sortir comme je peux y arriver
maman c'est sûr
par contre
en feed c'est pas mon objectif
j'aimerais bien c'est très cool
je cherche son
numéro
tiens au revoir on voit que ça fait nul
Ding et Abdou on a vu la caméra en
direct c'était assez clair que ça allait
faire un nul rapide
c'est pas la journée aujourd'hui Fatou
qu'est-ce que tu leur as fait
s'il vous plaît
tout ça là faites tous nul avant s'il
vous plaît
j'y crois pas la sorcière
[Musique]
un petit peu je pense
ok bon de toute façon ce qui me rassure
un peu c'est que dès qu'on a vu le début
des parties j'avais annoncé quand même
une nulle de Abdou Ding très très rapide
et une nul de rapport a rognan très
rapide et en 1h30 on a eu déjà de nul
donc
on cherche le point de règlement du tata
style qui non en fait c'est pas internet
mais c'est pas interdiction quoi du coup
le seul moyen que ce soit pas
ça leur fasse rien c'est si tout le
monde fait nul tout le monde fait le 23h
bon au final protestation
moi je pense à la retraite
c'est un mal argument
mon argument
en plus il est presque à la retraite tu
vois
j'allais dire c'est quoi la moyenne
d'âge
sous il est de
je dirais 84
un truc comme ça
guéri et de non je crois que
je note de tête je pense 92 sauts 94
guéris par âme il est de je sais pas
à peu près 96 je dirais au hasard
et après tu as qu'à 190 80 90
et
après tu as
erégasi Google
il a 18 ans Google 16 Prague 17 vente
forest doit avoir 22 ans je crois que il
a 18 en fait elles sont tous jeunes
rapports et les 91 un truc comme ça je
crois
et qui après
il y avait Ding 90 je crois
pas
il a 22 ans il est comme il est comme
forest
je vais vous dire car c'est 32 ans
92 d'accord
à rognan le plus vieux 40
rapport 26
Abdou 18
par 1 22 vous cache 16
[Musique]
irrigues
et après
j'ai pas les autres parce que c'est
attends je veux dire
Prague
et qui est mort
18e
[Musique]
stuff 32 ans
tu as oublié un U
il y a des bébés
1 2 3 6
j'avoue tu as bien eu
tu as oublié
presque envie de savoir
le gamer qui dit je veux pas être
méchant mais c'est qui Fatou
c'est pas méchant de demander qui je
suis
qui es-tu Fatou est-ce que tu peux te
présenter au grand public s'il te plaît
bonjour je m'appelle Fatou bonjour Fatou
enchanté cordialement
cordialement
je veux dire
je suis
il paraît que je joue aux échecs
qu'est-ce que je peux dire de plus
allez-y pose vos questions
j'y répondrai donc
quand tu as commencé à jouer aux échecs
quel est ton parcours et chez qui enfin
tout
à la fin de l'interview tu pourras me
demander un autographe si tu veux
palmarès
quand est-ce que j'ai commencé quand
est-ce que j'ai commencé quand est-ce
que j'ai appris
tu es forte non non
j'ai appris j'ai appris et un petit je
saurais pas dire à quel âge j'ai une
partie de moi je pense en tournant en
termes de mon club quand j'étais petite
où je savais même pas
j'écrivais pas bien du tout donc pas le
maximum 8 ans donc j'ai appris j'ai
appris petite
mais j'ai commencé à jouer
à 13 ans
on sera encore jeune mais
c'est déjà vieux pour ceux qui
commencent tout petit
et depuis mes 13 ans je
fais des compétitions
je joue aux échecs un peu
ce que je raconte toute ma vie parce que
c'est très long mais c'est passionnant
c'est passionnant
quel est ton métier
[Musique]
Merci Quel est mon métier j'ai pas de
métier j'ai pas de
[Musique]
gros suspense
je suis étudiante je suis étudiante
alors vous allez demander en quoi je
suis étudiante en
Master d'Allemands
bien vu
ouais master d'allemand me demandez pas
pourquoi Instagram
en plus
moi je sais je sais mais bon
je vais vers un métier en voie de
disparition c'est un petit peu triste
j'ai l'impression que Jean-Michel pigeon
il a dit que c'était un joueur d'échec
[Musique]
ouais
oh c'est bien tu t'es amélioré
donc après il me dit Spider c'est
sûrement joueur
et moi elle mange je suis je suis à
moins 10 ça parle allemand tout le chat
que des gens qui complimentent la langue
allemande
qu'est-ce que c'est beau
continuer pour tout vous pouvez écrire
à te parler en allemand
je vous en prie
je vous en prie ça c'est très très
non non vous aidera pleurer dans la
chatte c'est n'importe quoi
ça devenait très intéressant
à l'époque c'était avait
tous les logiciels frites etc qui est en
allemand quoi parce qu'en fait
et du coup c'était
c'était dès que tu joues contre Fritz le
logiciel Fritz et ben quand tu proposes
nul il faisait Rémy comme ça
par contre je suis une anecdote parce
que je sais que ça c'est une minute avec
avec Robin side
parce qu'en fait je sais pas dans quelle
langue
et ben peut-être que c'est portugais je
suis pas sûr mais pour proposer nul en
fait et ben c'est un truc genre patate
on fait quoi la pâte voilà et je crois
que c'est pas en quelle langue c'est la
patin je crois que c'est
en italien
je sais pas et en fait du coup
c'est à toi d'ailleurs c'était
en Espagne que tu avais fait ça
je sais pas peut-être fumé bref ça mille
en tournoi et puis il est là et il a
parlé espagnol
au fait est-ce que la PATA c'est la pâte
en espagnol enfin la patin en espagnol
c'est la patte du chat quoi tu vois
si tu veux je te pose ma pâte quoi tu
vois genre et
[Rires]
[Musique]
oui c'est mignon quoi c'est mignon quoi
si tu appelles Nala ça marche bien quoi
tu vois mais sinon
[Rires]
du coup voilà tu as raconté j'ai dit
mais j'ai pas confiance je ne connais
pas
ou l'impact c'est une égalité quoi en
gros
et
la nul en elle-même ben cette table là
oui bien sûr aux échecs on a des jolis
mots allemands
[Musique]
c'est ce que ça veut dire en termes de
lipidologie un manque de temps
[Musique]
urgence de temps
on va pas de passer sur toute la journée
à faire un cours d'allemand sinon je
vais je vais laisser ma place
crise de temps ah ouais peut-être ça
c'est mieux dans la traduction
qui vote pour que je trouve soit
bilingue à 20h
c'est possible hein
c'est pas c'est pas l'allemand ça
je connais pas tout non plus
dans la vie mais
je pense que je saurai quand même le nom
des pièces
en anglais moi en anglais
toutes les langues
bienvenue en arrivant
du coup parrain c'est intéressant ce qui
s'est passé à regarder
donc il y avait eu on s'est arrêté au
fameux fois H5 dames C2
qui empêche du coup j'ai 6 il va
préparer ta G4 6,5 réaction au centre
fou alors G4 prise attaque cavalier
prise et fougères 6 elle est à sacrifié
le pion que se passe-t-il si je prends
en G6
là clairement on va jouer sur la vente
de l'Autrement donc on peut imaginer
quelque chose
qui va les prendre G4 c'est un coup ou
pas Fatou
parce que je suis complètement drogué
[Musique]
et puis là il y a du coup derrière qui
du coup d'un projet 6 c'est peut-être
pas forcément ce qui va se passer
bonjour à toutes toutes questions
étaient possibles que l'analyse de ma
partie bug complètement arrosée ma dame
que j'ai suivi bien au final
normalement Lucas tu peux suivre la
partie mais bon après
l'ordinateur c'est assez bizarre parce
qu'il est bizarre quoi mettre
l'ordinateur il s'agissait les pièces
mais c'est pas pourquoi donc
fais attention en tout cas avec les amis
de l'ordinateur c'est pas toujours
il y a plusieurs possibilités si tu
étais déjà mort et qui propose de
sacrifier ta dame et qu'au final tu es
mort
bon ça là il y a une explication
après si tu as suivi vraiment tous les
coups
à partir du sacrifice de dames tous les
premiers coups
que tu sois déjà
totalement perdant au départ
c'est bizarre
grand peut-être bah c'était
joué
mais ça c'est quoi la différence du coup
arthamada
art madame
c'est quoi la différence je peux recette
ou pardon
tu prends là je prends là
pas simple
du coup
c'est pas simple franchement pas clair
on avait dit échec c'est la partie coup
brillant
ça a été joué par scarsen et le coup il
est en il est en bleu turquoise ce qui
veut dire que ça fait coup brillant
qu'elle va les prendre G4 de la part de
quinzaine
on aura du coup Tour Eiffel
pour défendre le fou
en prise
j'imagine que par habile
parce que je l'ai vu
et du coup il faut trouver un truc
derrière
la caméra
[Musique]
mais après cavalier prend ta vue pion
prend après
j'avais vu quand même l'idée de pourquoi
je fais ça quoi quand même
ok toi
ben écoute
j'aime pas du tout parce qu'il rentre
pas il sortait pièce donc là vous voyez
ici la jauge la jauge
elle a beau être
[Musique]
plus ou moins sur le pied d'égalité tu
vois
mais en pratique en fait je trouve que
le roi blanc au centre c'est chaud quoi
j'aime pas trop la pollution blanche
elle a pas de pied c'est vrai
qu'est-ce que tu en sais qu'elle a pas
de pied
il est jamais bien de toute façon
maintenant qu'est-ce qui va jouer
s'il prend parce que je suis cloué quand
même si je prends là
même cette position m'a l'air pas
forcément si bien pour les blancs vu que
j'ai une structure un peu chelou par
exemple prise prise
tac ma cavalier
F2F 6 pardon et là ok j'ai un pion ici
qui est un peu faible le chien aussi
à peu près égale mais je préfère quand
même les blancs les noirs excusez-moi
parce que la photo est noire quand même
mieux j'ai quand même deux pions liés
plutôt que les pions ils se sont moins
liés
et puis
le squelette
là on exolé là des pions sont isolés
tous les deux alors que nous on est lié
c'est quand même un peu mieux
OK
voilà du coup on est cloué donc du coup
il veut remplacer et du coup si je suis
leur fouet FC
[Musique]
d'ailleurs mieux que que j'ai 5
d'un coup bizarre mais ça paraît bien je
pense à roi
qui menace discrètement des cloués et là
je vais formater en fait non ça dépend
des billes
c'est complètement débile dommage
c'est créatif ce qui fait
par homme qui est mal au temps
alors so dirige annonce une nulle
imminente ça fait un moment que je
l'annonce déjà cette nul ils changent
tout et
[Musique]
oui oui mais bon c'était prévu
l'aider oui j'ai trouvé mon délim je
crois que ma cuisine je l'avais trouvé
en fait c'est nana qui joue avec
[Musique]
si je vous ai dit non on va pas on va
pas parler
[Musique]
non mais le chat n'est peut-être pas au
courant
bon Fatou elle fait allemand voilà
en fait parce que c'est vrai que très
souvent je jouais des coups au hasard et
du coup on parlait des coups jouer au
niveau des quand je lance un dé et puis
je joue avec Kevin je suis assez bon les
jeux
apparemment ce qui fonctionne le mieux
avec toi c'est de hasard bah oui je suis
pas mauvais mais en plus sans blague
je suis assez bon je suis assez bon
et
oui parce que c'est dur
il y a quelques années à Barcelone
j'avais mis 10-0 à un pote en pile ou
face
10 euros en pile ou face c'est quand
même c'est quand même sympa
c'est très drôle
mais
non déjà qu'on jouait pas mais non je
l'avais mis 10-0 en poker flash
c'est poker flash en fait c'est quand tu
fais au line quoi qu'il arrive
fais quoi
j'ai bien compris le principe
c'est pas mal
ta force au lieu de hasard
on n'a pas tous cette capacité
d'ailleurs Sami était là cette année
mais ça a mis l'aime beaucoup aussi les
jeux de hasard
avec lui il est trop content
les dieux du hasard sont avec Sami à
chaque fois en train de l'aider à
chanter quoi
bon c'est parti à faire nul c'est pas
très intéressant
je le suis
il faut pas entendre mais bien sûr c'est
du second degré ça
ok donc il y a eu blender sur Blender
moi je vois les cours rouges en fait
et apparemment mal coupé c'était c'était
ça qu'il fallait jouer ça ça en avait
dit et c'était un peu la crise du coup
la position s'ouvre et le roi elle est
complètement à poil il y a ça aussi en
l'air
près du sens
avec le visage je prends la cage du
cavalier là je peux me lancer de manger
ici ça va quand même beaucoup de sens
et du coup maintenant et ben je défends
ici je menace peut-être un lot de
fardams
d'un coup après le 5
[Musique]
je j'aime presque les blancs juste un
petit doute
que se passe-t-il sur le 5
je pense avoir
c'est à moi que je pose la question
tu arrives pas à répondre
[Musique]
en fait
parce qu'au final en fait ben plus tard
j'ai un fou qui va venir en C3
et va aller
je t'aurais pas du tout dit oui mais
actuellement je pense que c'est possible
que
remporte cette partie
mais avant le dernier couloir je
pleurais pas dit ça après la pollution
elle est hyper compliquée donc
franchement
il peut se passer encore des choses
mais c'est quand mon heure de jouer pas
tout
bah oui je sais c'est pour ça que
j'attends
[Musique]
5 d'accord donc pour l'instant je sois
je mange soit je fais quand même
donc on est obligé d'enlever le roi
d'ici
à la tout à fait normal
qu'on voit que là et puis c'est chaud je
commence à pas aimer la pollution la
position noire tu vois je me dis que
quand
et j'ai foulard qui arrive Fulla qui
arrive avec un cavale qui peut arriver
aussi sur G7
possible du cavalier H5 possible même du
cavalier G6 après fou c'est
franchement tu as l'impression que
que toutes les pièces blanches en fait
vont se réveiller et que ça risque
d'être super chaud le truc c'est que le
début très particulier peut en tout peut
prendre un sens maintenant là dans
quelques coups
souvent les trucs un petit peu foireux
au début ou bizarre inhabituel et puis
d'un seul coup
la beauté du jeu la poésie des échecs
tout se révèle
plus parfait
mais bon on va voir
si il fait grand rock
je pense qu'il va le faire
[Musique]
logique garder la
pour garder ça quoi
ton
ami mon ami mon meilleur ami
à la chanson de Lorient
ma meilleure amie
j'ai pas de référence à ça tu sais bien
que moi je suis pas second degré
non pas du tout
je te connais ah oui
encore une fois
depuis que je l'ai dit ça y est ça m'est
rentré je les gars j'espère en plus
[Musique]
dans ce cas une belle chanson c'est une
belle musique
pendant toute la journée
et
on attend peut-être un petit karaoké de
souffle
un petit un petit ma meilleure amie de
Loris ça peut le faire à la pause
peut-être
pourquoi attendre la pause
salut Benoît
à quel point la position est compliquée
que les deux joueurs en fait on fait
bourdes turboard mais bon c'est
tellement compliqué que que en fait
c'est humain quoi tu vois nous on a leur
dire en fait c'est facile pour nous on
leur dit on voit on comprend on teste
des choses eux pour eux c'est beaucoup
plus compliqué il y a beaucoup de
décisions en France c'est pas simple
les paroles même nous avec l'ordi est-ce
que est-ce que c'est si évident
comment ça commence déjà la chanson
je t'ai connu depuis quelques temps
mais si on se parlait peu souvent c'est
vrai
je te connais comme dans un livre ouvert
j'ai envie
magnifique
c'est pas mal les gens
c'est un bon début tu nous fais un petit
refrain pour
pour que ce soit carrément après
et attendez d'écouter Mylène Farmer tous
par là
un petit clip de qui chante libertine
qui traînent si jamais il y a des
intéressés non c'est pas vrai n'hésitez
pas c'est sur son discord voilà
si vous voulez écouter de quoi on parle
de quoi qu'est-ce qu'on chante
un bon appétit sur les parties on va te
le faire
[Musique]
nul mais on s'y attendait depuis un
petit moment on a eu trois parties nulle
on a eu so Guiri on a eu un rapport
aronial on a eu Abdou Ding et c'est
trois parties qu'on a vu quelques cours
on a dit ça allait faire nul très très
très vite
du coup du coup voilà
trois nuits pour l'instant au bout de
deux heures de jeu il reste trois
parties en quatre parties on a parram
avec les Blancs contre Karlsen perso
j'aime bien la position de de Carlson
mais bon ça reste égal pour l'instant
peut-être pas imaginaire d'un point en
souffrant et voir comment on continue
de sortir les pièces à un moment ouais
réghasi donc on a pas trop trop vu il y
a eu ces deux ah il est pas en mettre
pollution assez classique de l'espagnol
pour l'instant
donc les blancs qui vont jouer des
quatre à un moment donné
mais une pollution qui est assez
équilibrée pour l'instant
goes Prague c'était le bordel complet
complètement c'était hyper compliqué il
y a eu des gains ratés des deux côtés
enfin non il y a une grosse erreur de
Google qui n'a pas été puni par Prague
et là ils ont une partie qui est très
très difficile à jouer pour les deux
camps et on va voir un petit peu comment
ça continue mais en tout cas c'est c'est
chaud
ventes forest gamer ben c'est la partie
en train de regarder c'est une position
qui est symétrique quasiment il reste
que ces pions là et généralement très
souvent les Noirs jouent plus tard avec
des 5 pour échanger le pion sous-trale
blanc et voilà et pour l'instant c'est
un avantage blanc parce que du coup les
blancs en plus ça se passe grâce à leur
paire de fou qui active grâce aussi aux
pions le 4 qui comprend des cases quand
même
sur un air latino
vous avez l'album entière
je me fais l'album en entier
on va l'appeler
[Musique]
pour toi c'est bien toi Fatou qui fait
des scores de ouf au luxe traceur je
pense c'est elle elle est très forte en
tactique enfin on reconnaît la grandeur
puisque je perds quand même quand contre
Robinson
comme quoi
c'est pas tout quoi
je sais bien
[Musique]
ce qui va arriver les pièces vont
s'échanger peut-être qu'on peut imaginer
ainsi un cavalier F3 mode
avec
des gens de toutes les langues
je finis par apprendre
mais bon à part 4 mots
plus
c'est très multilingue
aux échecs pour dire que j'essaye de
de faire croire que j'ai des
compétences ailleurs
c'est pas toujours facile en fait
[Musique]
moi oui oui bien sûr
on recommence à parler de moi
oui je joue je joue
en interclone
d'autres questions non c'est bon je
crois
un club quel club le club de Jacques
1683 dans le chat le même club le
meilleur club
qui ne dit pas ça de son club c'est
sûrement un club breton ça hein
sûrement en N2 je crois bien
toujours à N2 pour le moment cette année
dérapage sur les Bretons
dans le coin dans le coin là
je suis pas
je connais pas du tout la Bretagne j'ai
certaines si j'ai mis les pieds mais je
joue en Bretagne
dans
quelques jours
voilà donc finalement je vais mettre les
pieds
Nantes Nantes j'habite à Nantes mais je
ne joue pas à Nantes
et mon prochain tournoi j'ai vu passer
ça mon prochain tournoi j'ai rien de
prévu à part cet été
je joue je joue [ __ ]
parce que toujours notre tournoi que
Saint-Lô
souvent les mêmes tournois je joue alors
je sais pas si tu le connais l'Open
d'échec d'avoine
très court je connais pas du tout avoir
des courir n'hésite pas à venir tu vois
il y a de la place
de la place je peux t'accueillir
dans mon lit
vous avez vu un petit peu elle essaie de
me de m'embrigader en son tournant
j'ai envie tu proposes après te sens pas
obligé
en fait ce que les gens savent pas parce
que là ils vont là ils vont ils vont
s'imaginer des trucs dans le chat mais
ce qui lance savent pas c'est que ça
fait un moment plusieurs mois qu'on a
prévu de faire un tournoi avec plein de
gens et plein de copains
[Rires]
moi aussi
des bisous bon aprèm
un flocon d'avoine
sont vertes les cieux sont bleus
paramètres pas bien
qu'est-ce que c'est égal en fait parce
que ce qui va se passer c'est que
personne va réussir à récupérer le vend
des 4 et ça risque de se terminer en nul
histoire
avec les pions en face l'un de l'autre à
priori
ça va pas jouer voilà
donc je vois pas trop carte son qui peut
la gagner je pense ça va faire une nul
assez rapide aussi ils vont ils vont
laisser les jeunes jouer ils vont
laisser goûter ses vent de Forest Kemer
ça va être sympa
de grands qui portent se reposer
moi je suis pas streamer
je suis
et puis en plus de vélo c'est forcément
moi qui vais gagner
soyons objectifs
n'hésitez pas à clipper à envoyer ça à
tous les autres partis
belle question d'un beau joueur
d'ailleurs
quel joueur quel joueur inspire le plus
et c'est toi
[Musique]
après si tu demandes un des joueurs
présents là dans le dans le tournoi
[Musique]
toi qui t'inspire le plus moi
donc
en vrai non
un défaut
voilà ça fait rien pour les bouches
regarde tac tac tourage 3 tours là 3 2
ça va faire un truc du style
et accompagner une belle proposition de
nulle je pense que ça risque de faire
mieux très très bientôt en tout cas
je pense qu'il a envie de faire nul
ben non mais bon il a un point et puis
un jour qui récupère son pion et il peut
pas faire tour de magie en fait il reste
plus de pièces et puis bon bah en fait
il a pas une mes parents c'est pas un
guignol non plus quoi il est pas bien
mais c'est pas un guignol non plus quoi
et puis et puis à un moment donné quoi
[Musique]
donc je vois pas trop comment il peut
continuer quoi
donc je vois pas
Google je sais pas c'est quoi sur Google
qui est fou ces trois ah je commence à
bien aimer la position blanche quand
même
je pense à bien aimé les blancs ici
quel joueur que tu aimes le plus dans
l'histoire des échecs et celui qui a le
plus influencé
j'aurais pu j'aurais aimé pouvoir dire
moi-même
je dirais pas
par Philippe
je non non c'est pas vrai c'est pas vrai
genre pas que que
mais non en vrai
moi j'ai vachement aimé casse pas
parce que bon c'est un peu ma génération
enfin
[Musique]
quand j'étais jeune mon père était
parfaits et puis on avait vu des pas mal
de
savoir comment c'est quand que tu étais
jeune
quand j'étais petit
une
simultanée avec casperov CARPA à Cannes
il y a très très longtemps
et d'ailleurs j'ai fait des livres
j'ai un livre Picsou que
avec avec
[Musique]
tout ça quoi
pas mal de
[Musique]
musique sans blague hein
je note que dans le chat trop belle
tu es belle
La Belle et la Bête
tu veux prendre celui que tu veux prends
celui que tu veux
[Musique]
mais
moi on sait plus
waouh
[Musique]
sur Youtube j'ai fait des des speedrun
avec des bestouf j'ai perdu une partie
l'autre jour 380
la partie est sur Youtube elle est assez
marrante l'autre jour je regardais
comment j'ai fait pour pour perdre ça
m'a fait rire
j'ai regardé la vidéo
c'est parti c'est compliqué c'est très
compliqué
nous aussi on a du mal à comprendre un
peu ce qui se passe mais j'aime beaucoup
beaucoup les blancs enfin plus ça joue
plus c'est logique vous voyez que les
pièces blanches qui vont taper sur le
pion G7 j'ai fuzcate qui va arriver le
tour en géant H3 celui qui avaler des
cinq
cauchemar
je pense que on va perdre dans quelques
coups
cavalier F3 et d'un point cavalier
regarde je te montre tu vois hop ça va
les prendre à prendre
c'est un échange
c'est sûr
je vois pas comment enfin ça a l'air
trop dur à jouer
à ce niveau là en fait ça m'a fait une
position qui est tellement tellement
facile je prends les blancs tout droit
qui peut être possible
j'ai dû fouter trois à ton géant H3
enfin j'ai trop de problèmes deux tours
sur la colonne j'ai le foot C3
c'est ouf parce que la partie en fait le
tour de la partie c'était là
c'est le tournant parce que tourgé 2
gros erreur qui pète puni par F14 bon
c'est compliqué encore c'est pas si
simple mais après tu avais 7 en fait et
ben la position elle est devenue
complètement injouable pour les Noirs
après 5 et grand rock il faut C3
et l'attaque des blancs elle est trop
forte j'ai un pionnement avec les blancs
mais pollution elle est complètement
toutes les pièces blanches qui vont
finir par s'activer alors que les pièces
noires sont toutes mal placées le roi
noir en G8 qui va attaquer par le fouet
3 par la tour géant
c'est facile à jouer c'est parce que les
placements de pièces maintenant ça
devient un peu
évident il y a pas de
de grosses réflexions on a toutes nos
pièces qui se dirige vers le roi
on a la colonne qu'on m'avait dit dès le
début
de cavaliers
malheureusement j'ai pas de pièces qui
défend ces quatre mais
c'est
comme ça et puis ça finit par une
tactique
à chacun et les pièces non protégées ou
des pièces alignées et c'est
un peu tout ce qui fait la tactique ce
qui crée la tactique notamment les
alignements de caisse là on le voit sur
la dame le fou après la prise du four la
dame et le roi attention attention à ça
alors attention juste Eva qui propose ça
ça
et ça parce que tu perds à la fin ça par
contre tu gagnes
lui
du coup là il va y avoir ton rêve je
pense forcément
avec la dame et la tour et du coup je
suis deux fois sur le fou quand une
seule fois pour le noir donc ça va
gagner ça pour les blancs mais du coup
il faut pas que je mange là mes 7 ou un
truc comme ça quoi
et les noirs
des cinq que je trouve parce qu'il y a
tellement de thèmes avec du cavalier
prend aussi ce que j'ai pas trop envie
de me commit pour l'instant avec la
veille à 5 ans plus tard éventuellement
l'idée
des trucs un petit peu bizarre
non on pourrait très bien parler avec
toi oui
je vois mes rayons X et un filet de plus
compliqué
pour les alignements
les doubles attaques
OK
mais
[Musique]
peut-être en plus que que d'autres
je pense qu'il a une revanche à prendre
il veut il veut vraiment
et puis
encore 22 minutes à la pendule qui a une
pression au temps
en fait
vont le rendre dans les bonnes
conditions et essayer de faire
nul quoi
ouais bien sûr ça
moi je crois pas du tout
je pense que ça va faire mieux
faut pas qu'il fasse toute nul ça va
être triste mais bon
ça ça
[Musique]
j'ai l'impression
de rendre le pion dans la meilleure
condition j'en sors ça limite
il fait froid
tu vois
et là si je fais juste un coup alors je
sais pas si je suis
juste défendre mon cavalier je la finale
la chose j'ai pas d'accord d'accord ça
on a compris
mais l'idée c'est de jouer un peu normal
quoi je tremble le pion changer les
pièces
je suis pas sûr que dessin qu'en fait
descends que j'ai pas j'aime pas trop
dans le sens où ben je donne un petit
peu des cibles etc
des sabots on va essayer de te calmer un
petit peu s'il te plaît je te remercie
il y en a qui se sont faits
sont pris des petits Vannes pour moins
que ça
plutôt pour moins de spam
à sa réclame en plus ça m'arrive
oups
[Musique]
sabot il mérite d'avoir son petit bain
donc il est fait comment je fais pour
pour retirer non mais en fait qui
méritent donc là c'est fait
ce qu'il y a aussi sur le chat il était
là désolé narcos j'ai complètement
fanimique en fait j'ai cliqué quand
quelqu'un a parlé du coup ça c'est
arrivé à toi
comment tu as fait d'ailleurs pour lui
rendre la vie
je sais pas comment ça marche en fait
je peux réessayer
en fait je sais pas si tu as les moi ça
fait déjà plusieurs années que j'ai les
raccourcis de modération
[Musique]
je me retiens et puis à un moment donné
ok il est revenu il a essayé et puis en
fait
faut pas prendre trop sur soi trop
longtemps c'est ça
par contre tu réfléchis tu réfléchis en
fait non ça va pas il y a un moment faut
lâcher les coups faut y aller
bonsoir point bonsoir Charles
qui a les cheveux là
est-ce que tu penses qu'on peut juste
donner le pion
tu as pas l'air très fort en pile ou
face Marco
non ça c'est sûr
ça c'est sûr
salut
mais en fait je vais pousser mon pion et
peut-être tu as dû échec tu peux me
casser un peu la structure tout ça
mais bon je pense aussi que j'ai tombé
le pion ici sans avoir trop de problèmes
je pense
tu mets peut-être un peu de temps le
récupérer quand même
en fait après sur le long terme je vais
te faire échec ça je vais te casser un
peu la structure et du coup peut-être
qu'il veut jouer là-dessus parce que
j'ai aussi cavaler échec imaginons alors
ça j'ai ça
et après manger 4
mais je suis pas sûr que ça marche si
jamais je le fais pas genre ça ça
vite
je sais pas lequel je joue
plutôt tu aurais fuite parce que sur ici
j'aurais une fourchette j'ai encore à
chaque quand même passé simple
non ça a l'air pas mal de faire échec
voilà et après tour ici qui avait les
bouts je vais manger du viande ça a très
bien
ce tour là aussi qu'elle a pas mal aussi
je vais faire ça et je vais essayer
d'aller manger le pion
et la structure elle a quand même un
petit peu cassé le cavalier qui arrive
pas à venir défendre c'est intéressant
peut-être que les noirs peuvent essayer
un petit pressing donc sur le long terme
mais comme ce pion qui va être un peu
arriéré en E3 j'ai une majorité de ce
côté là enfin passé peut-être que je
peux essayer d'y aller mais
ce pion il va nulle part mais il est en
fait essayer de rendre le pion dans les
bonnes conditions pour les blancs
mais je sais pas quels sont les bonnes
conditions
tu as 3 ou 2 maintenant
juste
tu prends des deux
conditions
[Musique]
de faire peur en fait avec la posséder
ben c'est pas peur en fait là j'ai quand
même deux pions en prise et un troisième
pure en prise parce que je me suis échec
ça va être ça
donc il y a peut-être pas le choix
mais
je suis pas encore
c'est bizarre quand même
[Musique]
franchement ça va faire nul parce que
les pions vont se changer je vois pas
comment je pense à faire nul placards
normalement
ça devrait
ça devrait être
je pense ça va faire mieux
c'est ça ou pas
[Musique]
les blancs vont encore une fois j'en
sais rien mais là vu la position je
pense que c'est un peu dangereux pour
les blancs nous structurels etc niveau
aussi activités donc les bandes on va
essayer d'échanger des pièces pour faire
1000 en fait
et du coup
un moment donné les blancs comme ils ont
plus tu vois elle est noire vont rester
d'échanger
d'aller manger le pion qu'ils ont de
moins quoi et le problème c'est que le
fait d'échanger le fait de manger le
pion ça va
provoquer des échanges et
ces changements à une position plate et
peut-être régale est nul quoi
mais non je crois pas trop après bon je
me trompe peut-être
mais je vois pas trop
comment est-ce que
[Musique]
non pas du tout
c'est dur c'est du 1h40
+ 30 secondes par coup
pour 40 coups
tu as 50 minutes d'ajout
plus 30 secondes par coup
pendant encore 20 coups
et du coup 60e coups tu vas avoir encore
une fois 15 minutes de rajout 50 minutes
d'ajout
en gros on est là pendant normalement
enfin il se peut qu'on soit là pendant 7
heures donc je sais pas comment vous
allez faire pour pour supporter enfin
tout pendant cette heure mais en vous
inquiétez pas
je resterai là
on va dire que j'ai l'habitude
au pire je suis
jamais aussi longtemps
je vois que
qui s'en prend tous les côtés
[Musique]
d'ailleurs en Allemagne ils s'en fout
des gars dans ce chaos
donc moi je suis 2300
quelque chose
je suis streamer depuis déjà tout le
début de semaine enfin depuis
maintenant 10 jours
[Musique]
elle aime bien trouver
un moment je suis à peu près entre la
moyenne et l'eau du chat
et les lots de stouffe
pas tout pour son efficacité
très claire
j'espère que ça vous a beaucoup appris
[Rires]
ah non je parle j'ai pas vu le tout
c'est pas d'après moi c'est c'est des
statistiques
statistiques fait partie comme donner
par chance
je me suis renseignée avant de venir
avec moi m'a fait venir pour pour
baisser un peu le niveau des
commentaires pour que ce soit plus
accessible au chat justement
donc c'est exactement pour ça que je
suis là du coup
c'est combien du coup ça m'intéresse ah
c'est secret c'est secret c'est
statistiques foot forcent les robinsight
si vous voulez savoir
mais elle est vraiment très forte
pas
c'est mon redoutable à chaque fois on se
fait des
battles problèmes
[Musique]
et une fois je l'ai réussi non
tu es sûr
mon généreusement parce que je suis
sérieusement tu m'adopes jamais
on peut le faire on peut faire autant de
particules
[Rires]
ok c'est rare
mais c'est vrai que non mais c'est dur
10 parties puis Fatou elle fait elle
fait souvent à peu près 40 ans en puzzle
donc bon pour faire 10 fois plus de 40
d'affilée
[Musique]
très très sympathique je te remercie en
tout cas passer sur le stream
de dire bonjour aussi ouais je te
remercie beaucoup très sympa de ta part
on va voir si tout moderne
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est difficile de dire tout le tout le
chat
j'ai qu'un écran avec
le chat d'un côté et le
l'écran de c'est pas de stream du coup
si c'est le stream enfin l'écran
particulier de tout de l'autre du coup
je vois pas tout ce qui passe
mais en vrai je kiffe pas mal aussi si
je
vous conseille pour progresser en
semaine et partir les problèmes sortir
tu as quel classement dark shadow
on va essayer
que c'est important c'est clair mais tu
as quel classement
maintenant que tu joues
il reste qu'à partir encore trois
turbots
et du coup bah voilà
OK
pour toi en fait il faut que tu fasses
de la tactique c'est important la taxe
fixe c'est important aux échecs
surtout ne cherche pas à prendre quelque
chose ça sur internet il y a il y a des
tonnes et des tonnes de contenu
mais c'est bien d'un côté et de l'autre
on s'y perd donc c'est pratique quand on
sait ce qu'on cherche exactement mais
pour les débutants notamment non non
faut pas s'il y a des il y avait
priorités et ne rien apprendre en fait
partie c'est vraiment apprendre juste le
principe les principes d'ouverture par
exemple ça te suffit pour commencer une
partie et pareil des petits principes à
connaître un peu tout au long de la
partie
faut faire un petit peu tout faut jouer
bien sûr il faut travailler après c'est
pareil des petites leçons ça dépend si
tu vas en club c'était que sur Internet
faut aussi trier ce que tu ce que tu
vois
mais forcément la tactique si tu fais la
tactique tous les jours ça tu peux le
faire même quelques exercices tactiques
tous les jours c'est la base c'est
vraiment bien et c'est le mieux pour
progresser en même très très loin la
tactique je sais puisque j'ai fait que
ça de ma vie et j'ai quand même réussi à
avoir un vélo
un très gros hello encore une fois qui
est encore
non mais en fait oui ce qu'elle veut
dire par là quand tu as dû de rien
regarder c'est qu'en fait généralement
il y a beaucoup de gens qui à ton
classement essaye de travailler les
ouvertures parce que j'en pense que le
début de partie et ben c'est les
ouvertures donc c'est la première chose
à travailler et c'est la plus importante
et du coup les gens se mettent à
travailler
les vidéos qu'on trouve sur internet
donc tous les sites ça peut être YouTube
ça peut être chez sable ça peut être de
partout des nages d'or sur 40 coups de
guéri ou truc comme ça alors qu'on a 700
hello ça ça n'a aucun intérêt c'est
complètement nul et c'est pas bien
en fait les ouvertures si vous voulez
c'est fait pour un public qui a déjà un
très bon niveau et donc après quand on
commence une partie c'est bien de savoir
à peu près où placer des pièces savoir
ce qu'on fait quel est notre plan
général dans les parties mais mais sinon
c'est pas à 700 € qu'on va travailler
les ouvertures ça c'est une perte de
temps vous savez que quand vous jouez
une partie contre un joueur de votre
niveau
très très vite vous allez sortir
des coûts on va dire théorique très
connu etc donc vous pourrez apprendre
tout ce que vous voulez par cœur et bien
vous savez que dans les cinq premiers
coups vous allez toujours sortir et vous
serez plus du tout dans vos dans vos
ouvertures normales
donc n'apprenez pas les ouvertures et
c'est plus à prendre les principes
qu'est-ce qu'on fait on sort les pièces
les pièces mineures cavaliers fous on
mêleront en sécurité on met des pions au
centre ça c'est la première chose
et ensuite on fait la tactique en même
temps donc la tactique donc c'est tous
les problèmes que vous êtes sur
cheesecom par exemple donc plein de
tactiques etc et puis voilà quoi un
conseil aussi pour la tactique ce que ce
qui est ce qui est important en fait
c'est que le travail de la tactique ça
permet de de reconnaître des schémas en
fait des schémas de gains de s'habituer
à des à des positions et à des à des
thèmes tactiques et souvent sur Internet
c'est proposé en vrac donc c'est à dire
on passe d'une fourchette à un clouage à
une enfilade à une double attaque un mat
et c'est un peu
c'est pas la meilleure façon d'apprendre
je pense qu'il vaut mieux travailler par
thème d'abord si possible et autant que
possible après il y a aussi des bouquins
d'exercice qui le permettent il n'y a
pas que Internet
mais par thème par exemple voir toute
une série de cloises puis toute une
série de fourchettes et bon ça quand je
dis tout une série c'est même pas dingue
10 on peut faire ça c'est pas 5
didactique du même thème qui vont faire
qu'on prenait qu'on connaîtra très bien
mais travailler par thème ça permet de
mieux mémoriser et plus rapidement
plutôt que de travailler en vrac je sais
pas si c'était clair
je sais pas je t'ai pas écouté
[Rires]
non mais oui je suis d'accord mais en
fait
non
mais non mais d'accord avec toi en fait
voilà l'idée en fait c'est que il faut
reconnaître ce qu'on appelle les
patterns c'est les c'est les positions
et les tactiques qu'on peut qu'on peut
faire quoi et en fait c'est un peu du
bourrage de crâne et moi je compare
souvent ça avec genre
[Musique]
tu sais quand tu passes parmi de
conduire
avant ça tu as le code code de la route
et bah c'est du bourrage de crâne en
fait tout ça tu vois et quand je l'ai
passé c'était juste débile il faut
prendre un truc par coeur mais là c'est
un peu pareil en fait parce que c'est
des brands des pollutions que tu dois
connaître et rabâcher rabâcher rabâcher
rabâché pour que ça rentre un petit peu
et voilà après par rapport à la tactique
par rapport aux méthodes enfin par
rapport Yama enfin par rapport à
tactique il y a plein de méthodes du
coup pour être efficace dans votre
calcul donc du coup ça aussi c'est
important de travailler un petit peu ça
ça va un peu où chercher comment faire
etc
mais la tactique c'est hyper important
et c'est vraiment ce qui va vous aider
le plus au début de partir ça c'est
clair et net
après il y a des bouquins pour les
débutants donc on en a déjà parlé
plusieurs fois mais il y a le bouquin
qui a été écrit par notre ami robinside
ici présent sur le chat en coopération
avec Kevin Bordy un big stream
que tout le monde pense doit connaître
donc il y a le tome 1 et le top 2 c'est
alors je sais plus comment il s'appelle
on a déjà fait des trucs hier c'est
gagner aux échecs même quand on est
débutant je crois que c'est ça le titre
débutant et je crois que d'ailleurs il y
a une commande
il y a une commande pour le chat
c'est ça
donc elle tome 1 et le tome 2 donc pour
ceux qui débutent n'hésitez pas à vous
le procurer c'est un super bouquin
très très bien écrit très sympa à cette
drôle en plus
et donc donc voilà
un peu de ça un peu de tactique
et les ouvertures c'est pas avant
beaucoup d'élo
ceux qui pensent vraiment que que au
niveau débutant c'est important les
ouvertures je
vous assure que non c'est il faut
connaître les principes en fait mais
ça regarde vraiment un niveau de
compréhension important et aussi selon
les ouvertures les ouvertures qui sont
qui contre totalement les principes et
c'est pas possible d'en avoir une
compréhension
encore meilleure donc très très
évolué des ouvertures c'est
un peu extrême certes mais c'est un
exemple qui est qui est qui est vrai
tu vois le petit Prague qui a les noirs
il a quasiment 2700 Elo il a 17 ans
et en fait
donc moi je le connais bien le petit
pragme parce que on a fait un stage avec
le club de canechec je suis parti en
Inde pendant pendant une semaine pour
faire un échange avec le Club de Cannes
où j'étais entraîneur
et en fait du coup Prague moi je l'ai
connu quand il avait 13 ans
et en fait dans l'idée à 13 ans 14 ans
il avait 2500 hello
bon c'est un génie très précoce très
très bon joueur et en fait maintenant au
début si tu veux et ben il avait 2500 et
quelques kilos et en ouverture il était
pas bon quand je dis pas bon c'est par
rapport à son élo quoi tu vois tu dis la
2500 et l'autre tu dis bah ouais le mec
il doit être calé en ouverture il doit
savoir des choses bah oui ça va des
choses parce que quand même c'est quand
même 2500 euros donc tu vois pas faire
n'importe quoi mais en fait moi je
considère comme moi à mes 2300 Hello
et bien j'étais bien plus calé que lui
dans les ouvertures
et en fait il est passé quasiment 2600 à
l'eau avant de vraiment commencer à
bosser les ouvertures
donc 2600 hello là c'est un petit peu là
j'exagère j'ai pas vous dire les gars
pas celui de 6 et après on va les
ouvertures c'est pas ça l'idée mais
l'idée en fait c'est que lui il a
travaillé les finales le milieu de jeu
le calcul plein de choses et à la fin
quand il est devenu fort vraiment il a
fait
donc dans l'idée
on voit bien que les ouvertures c'est
clairement pas le le plus important quoi
voilà donc
[Musique]
je vais vous dire la vérité
promis rien que la vérité que la vérité
j'ai eu un répertoire quand j'avais
environ je pense 9 ou 10 ans j'avais
1002300 hello et on m'a montré la
française et des trucs la slave et la
française voilà mais je connaissais rien
et j'avais répertoire de Poussin quoi tu
vois et j'avais ce répertoire de Poussin
jusqu'à quasiment mes 20 ans
ou ben en fait moi j'étais un gros
flemmard je jamais travaillé par ma main
et jamais changé en fait
et du coup donc à 20 ans j'avais 2250
donc en fait si tu veux je suis passé
quasiment 22,50 avant de vraiment
commencer à travailler les déchets et
les ouvertures
et
j'ai travaillé après dans la cylindre
dragon etc et puis là je suis passé de
1350 et voilà quoi mais ouais 2200 avant
de commencer vraiment à travailler
dehors
mais bon c'est pas parce que j'avais pas
envie c'est pas parce que vous
travaillez autre chose en fait j'ai
commencé à travailler les chèques à 2200
et l'eau tu vois
j'ai pas travaillé avant que ce soit
échec ou autre chose en fait j'étais pas
du tout un gros bosseur et
d'ailleurs je ne suis toujours pas je
suis pas un mec qui travaille beaucoup
les échecs de manière générale
mais bon donc voilà dans l'idée en fait
travailler un petit peu votre calcul
travailler en général mais les
ouvertures savoir un peu ce qui se passe
où placer les pièces vos idées générales
mais vraiment ça doit s'arrêter là quoi
ça n'a pas aller plus loin quoi parce
qu'après
parce qu'après c'est
c'est
jamais joué parce que vous êtes vers ça
ils vont jamais
jouer l'écouter oui parce qu'ils
connaissent pas non plus enfin et puis
en plus ce qui est important c'est jouer
quelque chose que vous comprenez quand
tu répètes 36 coups de la nage d'orf ou
de la française enfin juste qu'est-ce
que tu comprends ce que tu joues en fait
c'est ça qui est important si tu
comprends ce que tu fais ben vas-y mais
bon je suis pas sûr qu'à 733 hello tu
comprennes les subtilités de la nageoire
quoi par exemple le dragon ou de je sais
pas et donc en fait c'est c'est ça quoi
donc dans l'idée travailler pas
travailler pas les ouvertures c'est
c'est juste pas bon quoi
voilà et comment j'ai progressé j'ai
beaucoup joué dans un club dans un club
j'ai travaillé enfin je fais plein de
compétences
et le fait de jouer et faire quand même
de la tactique parce que j'avais quand
même des cours d'échec et en fait du
coup le fait de de
faire de la tactique de faire plein de
compétitions ça m'a permis de bien de
lui progresser quoi c'est ça
mais pas du tout
pas du tout
en travaillant les ouvertures ni rien
yes donc du coup il y a eu un fou le 5
de Prague là qui m'a l'air chelou
en fait là vous voyez qu'il y a un truc
bizarre c'est qu'il y a tout en prise
il y a lieu en prise il y a lui qui
défend lui va tout est connecté
et tout ça ça a pas l'air d'être bon
cahier des cinq c'est un coup qui peut
clairement se regarder mais c'est pas du
tout le conseil que j'aurais que
j'aurais
toujours fait là peut-être là regarde
faut calculer la
si je prends là il va sûrement y avoir
pu prendre attaque la dame menace de
manger le cavalier
du coup je peux pas manger le cavalier
tactiquement se défendu si je mange là
il mange là il a son cavalier et puis
m'attaque en plus une école ouverte
du coup sur X5 comment est-ce qu'on peut
punir cahier 5 c'est un coup qui a
clairement du sens
dans l'idée que sur cavalier 5 en fait
si tu manges là plus tard quand il
mangera là il y aura plus le cavalier en
prise
donc c'est intéressant
car elle prend aussi d'abord
intéressant tu manges là je peux manger
là et là à priori je crois que j'ai une
pièce mais il y a un peu de contre-jeu
peut-être avec un faux français 3 et sur
dame prend C3 vous voyez qu'il y a il va
y avoir un clouage
donc du coup ici sur brand par exemple
et ben moi il est un peu ouvert quoi bon
j'ai une pièce d'avance c'est clair mais
d'un point à trois bon
il y a un petit peu de contre jeu
donc faut 5 ça a l'air d'être vraiment
le coup oline il sent vraiment qu'il est
qu'il est hyper mal
et du coup et que du coup il veut
trouver quelque chose pour s'en sortir
quoi
mais bon pas que là pas simple
là je pense qu'il y a un gars il doit y
avoir un gars en tout cas la position
franchement
[Musique]
ça sent quoi c'est des fois tu as la
position en fait et tu sens clairement
que la position elle tient pas quoi il y
a tout en l'air il y a trop de problèmes
tu vois tu sens que la position ici elle
tient pas et que du coup elle risque de
se casser la gueule très très vite
donc je sais pas quoi faire
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire là
si je bouge le fouille à Tours
pendant un coup comme ça pas très malin
ce coup
d'échec je prends cavalier
est-ce que j'ai un coin intéressant là
proposé
si vous prend là je prends ici ça fait
sens
mais attention ce problème sur le long
terme du clouage là qui a pas l'air
qui a pas l'air compliqué quoi
je vois la jauge qui est monté en flèche
mais j'arrive pas à trouver le gars
S
[Musique]
peut-être que le coup c'est juste trois
B1 je te dis bah écoute j'enlève mon roi
du clouage et puis débrouille-toi quoi
en fait
la jauge normalement le milieu c'est
blanc et noir et plus elle monte plus
c'est que les Blancs ont l'avantage et
plus elle descend c'est que les Noirs
ont l'avantage
on a déjà parlé c'est un mauvais coup
échec et je prends le cavale
après je peux mettre l'ordi mais c'est
pas le but
on en a parlé
et la jauge tout à l'heure elle était
descendu et là elle bouge pas on se fait
avoir on se fait se croquer
pourquoi le H3 ne va pas sur G4 parce
que si je prends la
il va manger ici et en mangeant ici il
m'attaque madame et aussi attaque deux
fois le fou le cavalier F4 avec
d'ailleurs le fou et celui de fou prend
F4
parce qu'après on peut prendre le
Gabriel
c'est un petit peu mieux si
ce polinky je sais que c'est pas facile
mais il y a des cases sur l'échiquier
j'ai un peu du mal à suivre ce que tu me
dis
et prise là prise là et
ça a l'air pas simple c'est MP3
d'ailleurs peut-être plus peut-être
mieux d'ailleurs
et ça
il faut
[Musique]
quand même
quand même ça va gagner je vais te
l'ordi si on a raté un truc quand c'est
compliqué comme ça
[Musique]
en fait c'est la bonne ligne
et du coup
c'est un peu le cauchemar c'est un tour
des V8 qui empêche je prends un F5 en
fait c'est juste perdu
en fait c'est juste perdu je crois
pratique qui vient de
je pense qu'il est complètement foutu en
fait je pense ça va être fini ça va être
abandon quelques instants un tour sur
sur ce qui reste ouais tu veux qu'on
fasse un petit un petit tour sur tout ce
qu'il y a et puis après on fait une
petite pause
[Musique]
ça va arriver dans dans 20 minutes à peu
près
alors du coup on a 45 qui a un pion de
plus et qui a réussi à renverser un peu
la tension là il y a eu des 6
il y a la ligne qu'on avait dit tour des
tours
il a laissé le pire en prise pourquoi
donc
je ne sais pas moi je pensais qu'il
allait faire des sets
et 8
en fait c'est sur ça parce que et quelle
activité avec les noirs
après la question c'est pas que Carlson
va la jouer
quoi mais l'idée c'est plus qu'en fait
à quel point il va réussir à mettre la
pression à son adversaire
et ben là on voit que il est en train de
le raser hein
[Musique]
il commence à craquer et
aussi le fait de chaque fois c'est pas
facile de jeux contre 45
parce qu'en fait tu as un stress naturel
sachant que tu joues contre carcène je
sais pas si tu vois ce que je veux dire
mais
il a un aura quoi
et du coup tu tendance à plus respecter
donc
qui peut la gagner ici
ensuite on a quoi on avait celle-là donc
celle-là qui cette partie qui est très
solide
un peu par là il faut trois fautes on
reprend qu'il va 4 rois je sais
thématique les gars c'est de faire G3
pour filer le cavalier sans perdre le
pion en H3 on croise deux damla G3
le fou qui se replace en deux
et j'aime bien le noir
un tour blanche qui
n'aime pas trop bon j'ai le la tour en
E3 qui est mal placé et c'est aussi
d'ailleurs le fou en E2 qui est pas
terrible
parce que
j'ai un pion en 4 qui bloque un peu mon
fou et ça aurait été mieux si du coup là
tu vois les les Blancs ont enfin les
Noirs ont un foie active champion 4
alors que mon fou il est un peu passif
et là le pion raciste c'est une
faiblesse et ben il ferme bien contrôler
par le par le pion donc pour l'instant
[Musique]
j'ai une préférence une préférence
noire ici même si la pollution blanche
est quand même
assez solide mais c'est vrai que c'est
bizarre tout ça
ouais c'est clairement le placement de
pièces qui
est plus rassurant pour les noirs
et peut-être un jour même essayer de
faire un petit alors je parle bien plus
tard mais l'idée d'ouvrir un peu la
collection comme ça
mais après ça une partie qui va durer
celle là parce que les noirs sont mieux
mais après c'est pas simple de
progresser
un petit pressing donc Prague ben ces
pièces de plus du coup et autour des 8
là on peut peut-être imaginer alors tu
reprends des buts je suis pas sûr
il a mangé F5 sinon ce que je pensais
ce qui peut pas manger un F5 et que les
Noirs sinon il perd il perd là-haut mais
si il mange là je mange de la dame et
après je vais juste mettre mon fond
d'écran madame en C2 et j'ai une caisse
d'avance donc je pense que cette partie
là elle va gagner très très vite
salut Nathan
salut comment on dit comment tu vas en
allemand
après
[Musique]
il faut dire donc là
ça fait un peu peur c'est vrai alors que
Spagnol ça fait quand même un petit peu
un peu
et toi
c'est quand même plus beau tu vois c'est
plus 100 ans
les petites variantes qui sont montés
[Musique]
sur mon chat
mais toi tu peux le tu peux le mettre si
tu as la main
non j'ai pas la main
alors du coup
ici
[Musique]
il y a le pire qui peut tomber aussi
mais il faut dire aussi que piècement
donc je peux pas faire tout ce que je
veux tu vas manger là-haut c'est
compliqué donc je dirais qu'il y a une
belle activité pour l'option de moins
qui était donné un bon cavalier en E5
aussi qui va être très dur à déloger
parce que j'ai trouvé F4 ça va pas être
facile à faire
le pousser deux est mauvais
donc avantage blanc mais être précis
être précis
pour faire quoi en fait
mais après quel est mon plan en fait
quel est mon plan après pas simplement
parce que genre ça ok faut que je joue
F4 en fait je vire lui quoi
je vous dis n'importe quoi
mais surtout autour des 8 un truc comme
ça pour virer la tour et faire un
en tout cas les pièces sports sont quand
même assez
assez active donc ça peut
ça peut être intéressant
[Musique]
j'ai quand même plein de choses j'ai du
cavalier F3 échec du damla c'est un peu
compliqué à tour Eiffel j'aime bien
là ça rejoint un petit peu l'idée que tu
l'avais hein
je fais F4 j'attaque là fourchette et en
plus je défends ici là c'est intéressant
là on aime bien là
là on aime bien
yes bien sûr alors je l'ai pas encore
fait celui que Nathan on avait parlé je
l'ai je l'ai pas du tout
proposer mais ceux qui regardent le live
via YouTube et ben surtout n'hésitez pas
à vous abonner à la chaîne parce que
c'est vrai que que
on y pense pas moi je suis sur twitch
donc du coup je pense pas forcément à ça
mais ceux qui sont sur ceux qui sont sur
sur Youtube n'hésitez pas à vous abonner
c'est gratuit et vous aurez les notifs
des de tout ce qu'on fait à chaque fois
sur Chess.com
donc n'hésitez pas à vous abonner
fais attention une petite pause la
première
la première pause du stream au bout de
trois heures dix ça te va
du coup on va partir sur une petite
pause on va mettre la caméra si vous
voulez sur sur vous voulez 46 vous
voulez Google
sur Magnus
je vais vous la mettre de seconde
c'était laquelle déjà qu'on avait dit
quelle heure
[Musique]
on va pas s'entendre
[Rires]
je vous dis à tout de suite la caméra
qui saute incroyable
allez reposez-vous bien et dans quelques
minutes
quelques minutes on revient
caméra qui saute un petit peu mais
normalement ça devrait
marcher à tout de suite
exactement
désolé maman désolé
promis je cours plus vite la prochaine
fois parce que je suis au cinquième
étage c'est pour ça
ouais
oui j'ai oublié de remettre mon micro je
suis dingue
ouais j'avais mieux que le micro et je
suis revenu et j'ai oublié de
comment est-ce que moi
c'est important pour les faits de
préciser ce qui évidemment c'est
important
alors du coup je remette la caméra sur
caméra sur lui
et on va essayer d'aller voir un peu la
partie voir ce qui se passe
alors
c'est pas mal de choses
il montre le roi ce qu'il normal mais la
tour en A4
tu reprends à trois petit tactique
regardez
tu reprends sinon j'espère de la tour de
tu reprends à 7 on reprend des 6 là il y
a deux pions de plus du coup pour un
pour les noirs et donc là ça va être
juste technique
pousser le pion et je pense que c'est
gagnant en plus regardez le roi noir et
couper ici du coup en fait juste je
pousse je monte le roi et ça va être
abandon dans quelques instants on est
vraiment arrivé au bon moment
salut Fatou salut
comment va-t-il
[Musique]
participer à la défense
du pion ici le roi il est coupé par la
tour le roi ne peut pas il y a une sorte
de barrière qui s'est créée entre la
tour et le roi
je suis là pour poser les questions
c'est fini en plus là c'est fini ça va
être abandon
par quelqu'un du chat est-ce que tu
penses qu'il va jouer un coup
un coup ce qui va jouer
direct ou pas
non mais oui on a le direct j'ai pas le
lien j'ai pas le petit lien je pourrais
le retrouver mais bon j'ai un peu la
flemme comment est trop loin de la
pendule
je pense qu'il va abandonner au prochain
coup enfin là je pense qu'il va pas
jouer là maintenant tout de suite
[Musique]
c'est juste
ça
donc j'ai vu hier Magnus hyper dix
points pour l'instant
et je pense pour qu'il perde pas de
points il faut qu'il fasse 4 sur 4 je
pense
parce que si il fait 3 et demi
je pense qu'il perd environ 6 gagne il
prend environ trois points par victoire
donc la 23 sur 3 6 9 c'est pas assez
je pense il faut qu'il fasse 4 sur 4
pour gagner des points
je sais pas si vous imaginez à quel
point c'est dur de prendre des points
quand on s'appelle manuscrite
et l'eau
le peintre
ça fait mal
donc moi qui limite la casse parce que
une nuque plus chère peut-être pas quand
même parce que il doit perdre au moins
deux points pour la nul et il en gagne
trois points de victoire comme ça
enfin il faut quasiment une victoire
enfin c'est chaud quoi
c'est trop dur
mais le pire c'est qu'on joue pas contre
des
[Musique]
contre des plots quoi
chaque adversaire chacun adverseur sont
très fort quoi c'est dur
et
réfléchis quoi par hassez pas mais il va
abandonner je pense qu'il est blasé et
que
dépit s'il a un truc mais bon
il va tranquillement abandonner
tout ça
je pense qu'il savait que
s'attendait vers la nulle qu'il avait
après il a rien à perdre de jouer pour
quelques coups
passer à autre chose plutôt que de
juste s'arrêter net tu t'en vas
le fait d'être sur place tu poses ta
tête un petit peu
tu joues quelques coups et puis tu dis
même ça tu peux même faire ça
c'est marrant
[Musique]
le roi et puis tout simplement
et il sait bien que sur 5 il fera tout
aussi
[Musique]
donc surprend ben moi je prends bien sûr
le bon pion c'est ici et une fois qu'il
vient là et ben je recoupe
et ouais on coupe et recoupe
en fait il joue juste par
comme ça mais bon
il devrait toi aussi ça
aussi si ça va
[Musique]
ça va se terminer là dessus
les gens aiment bien voir les gens
abandonnés en direct
du coup ah oui oui c'est la spécialité
les gens adorent la fin de la partie en
direct voir le moment où il abandonne
donc là vous allez le voir normalement
maintenant moi je pensais qu'il allait
l'abandonné un petit peu avant
la suite de la partie les gens sont
intéressés
donc vous avez les blancs de carvana
donc on va se mettre encore cette tour
qui a un peu mal placé
en E3 et ce fou eux deux qui est
derrière son pion
ça va pas bouger
le cavalier 3 G7 cavalier 2 et la cave à
laisser 4 poser problème il faut faire
attention toi aussi c'est cavalier F3
reviens
OK
ok c'est quoi le problème
il y a pas grand chose
donc là c'est une proposition un petit
peu implicite de nul
tu vois
tu fais un petit
tours là je reviens bah s'il vient là en
fait ça va répéter ça va faire nul
mais c'est pas trop le genre à vouloir
faire nul généralement un jour qui aime
bien jouer tu fais pas un très bon
tournoi d'ailleurs
donc peut-être qu'il va falloir se
refaire
ça vraiment je suis étonné que que
parrain n'est pas encore abandonné
[Musique]
je suis vraiment étonné parce que je
c'est une finale vraiment vraiment
facile
sur son visage pour voir ce qui ce qui
reçoit exactement
[Musique]
ok bon cette partie on va voir un peu
s'il y a une répétition ou pas le tout 8
donc du coup
alors on s'est arrêté
autour des 8 allez ici
donc il y a eu du coup je prends F5 pour
prendre des un
qui vient manger à trois et il faut les
trois pour cacher un petit peu les
pièces
tourger 4 qui vient me lasser fou c'est
4 échec
d'en prendre à trois rois des deux donc
on voit qu'il se balade et quand même
des pions pour pour le noir mais bon ça
devrait quand même aller hein
il y a un pion pardon pour pour la pièce
mais bon ça devrait perdre assez
facilement
[Musique]
4 pourquoi tu joueras à C2 pour enlever
des échecs et tu te montres la dame et
tu fais 6 un truc comme ça ça va ça va
gagner extrêmement facilement pour
Google on peut imaginer aussi que un
serrage de main
[Musique]
qui peut arriver très très vite
reposé sa main sur son visage
mais hésiter à jouer ou abandonner je
sais pas
ils ont changé les pions comme on avait
dit
ils ont changé
abandon est un coup peut-être même le
meilleur coup ici
mais le roi là vous allez voir la tour
qui va venir bloquer un jour rapidement
qui permet de d'empêcher le roi de venir
participer à la fête
roi à trois et bien
joué pas besoin de calculer en fait une
fois que tu fais ça ben tu calcules plus
tu vois
calcul plus vu que tu as déjà le roi en
fait le pronostic c'est qui va
abandonner avant
[Musique]
c'est pas grave mais
là il va être vraiment mentir je crois
qu'il a il a un pari avec avec Prague
ils ont dû parler ensemble tous les deux
du coup
ce qu'on dit ce que je dis Prague
c'est là que
ça c'est vraiment une finale facile
ça va être la finale qui va se
transformer en
comment ça s'appelle
[Musique]
un peu si Patou je prends votre lit pas
touche salut Patouche donc pour donner
c'est non en fait on va ramener le roi
le pion le roi le pion
et une fois qu'on arrive là et ben mon
rap va pas sortir vous voyez ni l'un ni
là parce qu'il a tout et le roi blanc et
pourtant on va quand même gagner avec la
fameuse méthode de Lucena
c'est un truc très connu
et
[Musique]
du coup bon à ce niveau-là c'est c'est
final par jouer quand même hein
je peux vous le montrer si vous voulez
alors je vais vous le montrer
alors les blancs vont attendre parce
qu'ils ont rien de mieux à faire
d'accord
comment faire pour gagner en fait ce
qu'il faut faire premièrement il faut
dégager le roi blanc d'ici pour pouvoir
essayer de sortir avec le rang donc on
va faire ici tour et échec déjà le roi
plusieurs cases soit je vais ici soit je
vais bah là
si je mets le rang c'est trois ça perd
en un coup parce que j'ai roi C1 avec
dames au prochain et en plus avec ces
constructions vous voyez qu'il y a pas
du tout de maths par là
parce que je fais quand même et sur
échec et ben pardon je vais arriver
sur échec et ben je m'attend devant et
il y a pas de maths et j'ai une dame
d'avance
ensuite quand je fais échec le roi va
partir ici donc dans le doute on le met
milieu maintenant quand je suis ici vous
voyez que je peux sortir mon roi mais si
je bouge le matin
si je rêvais en arrière ça a pas de sens
non on va tourner en rond quoi ici je
vais ici et chaque
voilà je pourrais d'ailleurs faire un
roi ici
et d'ailleurs sur échec je mettrai la
tour d'avant alors normalement en fait
c'est pas comme ça je vais d'ailleurs si
vous voulez vous montrer notre manière
enfin
je vous montre juste un j'ai repéré sans
faire exprès on recommence tout le début
je suis désolé
je vais tricher je vais mettre un tour
ici voilà
ce que je voulais faire juste
pour vous montrer je voulais faire ça
échec voilà voilà échec voilà échec
voilà là vous allez voir que maintenant
si je continue à monter mon roi il y a
toujours une enfilade
et du coup en fait ce qui va se passer
ici c'est que avant de sortir le roi une
fois qu'on a créé cette petite cette
petite porte pour le roi et ben il faut
qu'on mette la tour sur la Cinquième
rangée donc si j'ai les noirs sur la
Cinquième rangée si à l'inverse j'ai des
blancs ça sera là quatrième rangée et du
coup l'idée c'est de regarder bien
je me la tour sur la Cinquième rangée
donc lui il va attendre parce qu'il a
rien de mieux à faire
et maintenant tour là et chaque voilà
échec
voilà
échec voilà
échec
et toi
ce qu'on appelle un pont qui permet en
fait de couvrir avec la tour et
d'empêcher la suite des échecs
et pourquoi pas du coup
la quatrième rangée parce que le roi
blanc pourra venir attaquer la tour ce
qui pose un problème à notre défense ici
la tour de laversaire est déjà sur ce
qui a mangé et ben en sortant je vais
réussir à l'attaquer
par exemple
regardez
si au lieu de faire ça je mettais par
exemple
pour empêcher ok échec voilà je sors
échec et je t'attaque ça va quand même
marcher
là enfilade et ben non pas un filet
dans ma parade
voilà c'est ce qui pourrait se passer
et c'est ce qui va se passer sauf que là
la tour elle est déjà sur la Cinquième
rangée
donc du coup ça va gagner encore plus
facilement
et c'est incroyable qu'il la joue encore
ça c'est quand même une finale qui est
quand même hyper enfantin
il pense au chat il pense au chat en
fait si tu veux
tu veux en fait
au niveau du chat ou tu vois même toi
moi j'aurais déjà abandonné
il a abandonné
mais à ce niveau là c'est tellement la
base c'est final là c'est très très
facile et du coup en fait ça m'étonne
qu'il la joue quoi juste
donc il fait réviser Magnus mais ok là
c'est vraiment une finale c'est
ultra ultra simple pour lui si vous
voulez Magnus c'est une là c'est comme
si le matin
c'est comme si il devait gagner roi dame
contre roi
c'est aussi simple que ça c'est
exactement la même
ok donc
c'est terminé
je vais mettre la caméra si vous voulez
sur Google parce que c'est la partie qui
va se terminer je sais que vous aimez
bien le serrage de main
[Musique]
de défendre ici
les clés de serrage de main
et on va avoir un abandon je pense
peut-être bientôt de Prague qui va être
matte dans quelques coups
personne a gagné non il a gagné grâce à
arrachage demain
[Musique]
là peut-être pas non
mais en tout cash qui revient bien parce
que il avait il était mal parti dans ce
tournoi puis la battu quand même il y a
deux rondes paramètres hier il a fait
une contre
47 et là il va battre Prague donc au
cash qui qui revient bien dans cette fin
de tournoi donc ça fait plaisir quand
même de voir ça après j'aurais préféré
qu'il battent notre adversaire que Prat
que j'aime beaucoup pragosi
mais
comment est-ce qu'on peut mater là
ma jolie le joli Madcon trouver Google
dites-moi bien s'il vous plaît dites-moi
que il va voir le tour des 6
dites moi qui va avoir tour des 6 qui
menacerait
qui menacerait
tourpage 6 échec la possibilité de fou
et sur pion prend j'aurais dame prend
qui fait mat
ou H4 bande originalité
c'est très bien tourage 4
c'est super bien mais bon attendez si
c'était plus joli
la partie hyper hyper intéressante la
partie c'est ouf mais elle sait jouer en
fait au 16e coup
parce que le 16ème coup oui ça va sans
gagner aussi
l'abolition avec le plan gagnante le roi
noir est trop faible ça va gagner
mais ici la partie qui s'est joué à ce
moment là il tourne pour le blanc
et la place de ton G2 et d'un il aurait
fallu jouer
F34 ça donnait un énorme avantage au
noir
[Musique]
je sais pas
du coup là j'ai qu'est-ce que je pouvais
pour le tirage demain il reste deux
parties encore
il reste carwana irrigasi c'est celle-là
il y a pas eu la nul qu'on avait on
aurait pu avoir un cavalier des deux
toi aussi ce qui avait F3 tours 8
cavalier 2 il a fait froid à 4 donc il
veut jouer
Caval F3 fous et 6 cahier deux fois 4 ça
va faire nul attendez vite la caméra
la caméra sur sur
[Musique]
hop
ils vont s'arracher la main
c'est vraiment pour vous c'est pour vous
qu'on fait tout ça n'oubliez pas tout ça
c'est pour vous qu'on le fait
pas très rapide mais
c'est ok donc là normalement cavalier F3
oui il y a les fous c'est nul
car wash
pas trop trop progresser
non pourquoi il met la caméra là
[Musique]
c'est fini je suis désolé ben oui mais
en fait on a eu le bug donc caméra sauté
et du coup on a raté le serrage de main
je suis deg
[Musique]
Astel tu as loupé le troisième
déception déception
va être viré des commentaires à cause de
ça
parce que là on est à 3h50 de stream
tout et c'est quasiment quasiment la fin
en fait il reste une seule partie
évidemment
tous les jours
Fatou elle vient boum 3h allez faites
tous nul cassez-vous vous pouvez vous
voir
on retourne demain
ils sont tous mis d'accord
ça c'était ça
demain c'est repos
ah oui demain
ça reprend du coup vendredi avec Kevin
Kevin Thériault à la technique
le 28 aussi ah oui le 28 je pense aussi
que faire ça risque de terminer très
très vite le 28 si vous avez juste trois
heures à perdre
pour venir sur le stream vous savez qui
qui sera
aux commandes
donc là en plus on va avoir une partie
qui va se terminer très très bientôt
parce que après la finale de Tours ici
tout reprend ici on peut s'attendre à un
petit tour 8 échec
ici en A6
3 contre 2 ça gagne jamais
ça va faire nul à fifou
mais on va regarder
de défense cavalier j'ai 5 empêche F4 F4
quand même
Chris
2 faut prendre H3 et c'est une petite
tactique alors ça je sais pas sûr qu'il
avait vu ou pas on va voir j'ai pas vu
la suite
il faut prendre H3 sur puis on prend H3
il y a un très très joli coup
et du coup c'est cavaler a priori va
être perdu parce que la dame peut pas
défendre à la fois la tour et le
cavalier donc il y a eu G3 dame G6 Dame
des 5 d'un point des 6 donc en fait il
s'est fait un petit peu arnaquer avec
l'idée de
faut prendre un H3 là
après tout rêve 5 il a décidé de
sacrifier la qualité enfin le pion
pardon sur ça en fait ici c'est vrai que
en fait en termes de pratique peut-être
qu'il a raison
ou pas
parce que là ici
voilà c'est quand même pas mal mais
c'est vrai que dans celle-là peut-être
que les noirs peuvent essayer de pousser
un tout petit peu parce qu'ils ont un
bon cavalier contre le mauvais fou
par exemple ton F5 F6 roi quelque part
et à regarder la tour essayer d'aller
manger des pions etc ça peut être
en tout cas un peu poussable
mais là ici il a fait tourner 5 direct
pour forcer un petit peu tout ça quoi
genre s'il prend pas des sacs j'ai un
peu passé donc c'est pas la même
qui attaque aussi
ici donc ton récit t'en prends ton point
je pense que cette évolue en fait de la
part de ventes forest de rentrer
là-dedans plutôt que dans l'autre parce
qu'il préfère avoir un peu moins
qu'avoir un mauvais fou contre un manque
cavalier qui faisait peut-être nul aussi
mais c'était pas simple et celle-là a
priori elle est nulle assez facilement
qu'est-ce qu'un mauvais fou et un bon
cavalier alors merci pour tes bonnes
questions
on m'a dit que tu étais entraîneur donc
j'aimerais vérifier
alors en fait ici le mauvais fou
pourquoi parce qu'en fait il est de la
même couleur que ses pions ce qui veut
dire admettons allez je joue ça juste
pour voir et ben j'ai mon fou qui est
qui a pas trop de cas déjà pour sortir
pour s'activer et le pion il a une
couleur que mes pions
qui sont ici vous voyez et du coup ce
qui va se passer c'est que mon fond en
fait et ben il pourra pas vraiment
bouger librement parce qu'il y a
toujours des pions sur ces diagonales
avec tout en décades puis tours C4 mais
ce qui est passé c'est qu'à un moment
donné il faut être surchargé devra
laisser sûrement un pion et on pourra
peut-être en profiter pour pour manger
un pion le four en C2 c'est une mauvaise
pièce parce qu'il peut pas vraiment bien
s'activer si je mets le fond en dessin
que c'est pas la même
mais j'ai un peu du mal à le mettre en
dessin comme ça mais il y aura quand
même toujours un tour de 4 et du coup
j'ai un peu du mal quand même à l'amener
ici
mais dans tous les cas
cette pièce elle est pas très bonne et
le cavalier il est quasiment intouchable
si tu veux parce que moi je fais un M6
des fois on se cavalier je vais être mon
droit derrière pour défendre le pion et
mon cavalier contre le rond tout donc il
bloque un pion qui bloquera le fou plus
tard
et puis tous les petits pions peut être
faible si jamais le fou n'arrive pas à
s'activer quoi
après il y a plus grave comme comme
mauvais fou comme par exemple souvent on
voit dans la française dans La Française
des fois on voit vraiment le fameux fou
de casse blanche des Noirs qui est une
horreur absolue
là le flou blanc il est pas si mauvais
que ça quoi mais c'est quand même un
mauvais fou par rapport au cavalier quoi
et du coup peut-être que juste gamer il
s'est dit bon je préfère
donner le pion
que que de jouer cette finale là qui est
assez facilement nul il a fait à 5
donc là il menace échec
ça et ça et le pion sera perdu
bonne soirée
un petit tour à trois peut-être tour à
trois qui va
fixer la Tour Blanche qui empêchera la
Dent Blanche de me lasser échec et ça
par exemple
toi ici
et ben
et ben voilà quoi moi je vais faire ça
je vais attendre et puis je vais monter
mon orage on va chacun monter nos rois
ici et attendre et la Tour Noire partira
pas sinon c'est moi qui ira manger le
pion en 6 le temps blanche part pas
parce qu'elle doit défendre le pion à 5
et normalement on est tous les deux
mobiliser donc j'ai un pion de moins
avec les avec les blancs mais bon ça ça
passe pas en plus dès que le roi se met
sur une case comme celle là souvent
échec et je prends là donc du coup les
possibilités noirs sont quand même assez
limitées donc ça va faire nul je pense
assez facilement tout ça enfin
je pense qu'aujourd'hui on fait le
record
apparemment c'est ça
18 ans et
23 ans
23 ans chez
Van de
et 18 ans chez gamer
donc il y a eu tout ce 5 il attend
[Musique]
donc trois actes menaces
donc on va avoir ici
et
puis voilà puis voilà
et attendre rien de spécial ça va faire
un nulle façon cette histoire
ça va faire nul et vous avez la caméra
en tout cas pour le serrage de pâte
et ça c'est fini assez rapidement je
pense
quand même 4 heures de jeu
c'est
en fait je suis choqué parce que
parce que
bon on a fait 7 heures quasiment tous
les jours
donc aujourd'hui la 4h parce que j'étais
pas là
depuis le début
un petit résumé svp
à part goutesch qui a fait une belle
partie donc c'est une partie très très
compliqué hyper compliqué c'est un
bordel et gokash qui a battu Prague son
compatriote son compatriote allemand
indien pardon je dis n'importe quoi et
on a eu aussi du coup victoire de Carl
Seine avec les Noirs contre parram et
que des nuls et quasiment rapide
d'ailleurs donc on va voir un petit peu
ce qui va se passer quoi
salut
[Musique]
plaisir de lire ce message
je vais pas rester et ne fait que passer
mais trop contente d'enfin voir une
frimeuse pour commenter les parties
merci Fatou
voilà mais c'est vrai qu'il y a c'est
vrai qu'il y a pas beaucoup de filles
qui commentent les chèques de manière
générale donc c'est cool d'avoir aussi
alors aussi des films de temps en temps
en tout cas merci pour ton commentaire
le chamec
je commande tout qui commente les
déchets c'est un petit peu différent
c'est ça moi j'ai pas changé de sexe non
moi par contre
du coup on fait le petit point
classement score pour
le résumé
[Musique]
avoir un truc et au final derrière on va
vite oublier
comment
des fois j'arrive pas à comprendre ce
que tu dis non tu me parles allemand
bizarre au revoir à quelqu'un du chat
tout va bien tout va bien
alors du coup point classement donc on a
du coup à torov qui maintient du coup la
tête avec 7 sur 10 donc il reste encore
trois parties derrière 7 sur 10 donc un
demi point d'avance sur guéri qui lui a
induit en avance aussi sur 4 scène et
Wesley so
derrière à 5 points et demi on a carwana
à rognan puis à 5 sur 10 à la moyenne on
a du coup rapport et Prague
prak est à +2 qui était à deux victoires
qui a perdu deux parties presque
consécutive on a dingueren à 4h30 sur 10
décevant tu me dis rien qui était à mes
favoris dans le tournoi
qui remonte pas mal ou qu'est-ce qu'il y
a 2 et demi sur trois sur les trois
dernières parties
ou qu'est-ce qui passe à 4 points sur 10
on a parram à 4 points aussi vente
Forest et à 3,5 heures à 3 à noter que
vente Forest est Vincent kamer jouent
encore leur partie ça devrait se
terminer par la nul du coup je pense
qu'on va avoir vente forest qui va
rejoindre goût cash et param avec 4
points et que Kemer va aussi rejoindre
ergasi avec trois points et demi sur 10
par rapport aux appareils je vous les
montre c'est comme ça il reste du coup
plus que la partie de la table 3 entre
one Forest et gamer qui devrait se
solder par un
maintenant dans quelques instants je
pense pas que ça va beaucoup jouer
voilà donc je remets les caméras
car rejoint
je pense qu'il est juste pas intéressé
par un tournoi comme celui-ci
parce que c'est un tournoi qui quand
même ultra long donc aujourd'hui ça fait
que 4 heures pour la partie ce qui est
bien mais
généralement la partie qui peut durer 7
heures et Carouge quand même plus trop
aux
échecstream en fait et du coup il
attendait
c'est un streamer maintenant et Caro
et je vois un tournoi où il faut passer
7 heures par jour pendant deux semaines
juste ça m'intéresse pas quoi donc tout
simplement c'est normal que ça sera pas
là
mvl il a pas été invité et puis même si
il l'avait été
c'est un temps qu'il lui plaît pas parce
que c'est trop long et puis le cadre est
pas terrible
donc c'est pas un tournoi qui
[Musique]
qu'il aime jouer en tout cas
donc même s'il avait été invité je suis
pas sûr qu'il
serait allé dans tous les cas
mais
[Musique]
du coup voilà sinon Fairuz jab il était
bon il y a 2 ans il a eu un gros
problème si vous voulez avec avec
l'organisation et du collant il veut
plus
il veut plus
il veut plus participer à cet endroit
c'est que il y a deux ans si tu veux il
avait fait un tournoi moyen bon ça c'est
des personnes en fait dernière onde où
sa partie je sais plus quoi qui et il
les gagnants
et en fait il y avait un départage c'est
plus entre qui et qui je peux pas savoir
je me souviens plus
peut-être que c'était entre vent de
Forest les guéri mais bon c'est pas
important et en gros
ils ont pas voulu attendre que toutes
les parties se terminent pour faire les
départages de glitter rapide et ils ont
dit tiens on va aller faire dans la
salle
on va aller faire dans la salle pendant
qu'il joue donc après pas de souci mais
ce qui s'est passé en fait c'est que du
coup ils ont dit non on va prendre cette
table là où vous êtes vous installé on
va vous prendre votre place pour faire
le départage ici et du coup il a dit bah
ça va pas ou quoi enfin je suis en train
de jouer quoi tu vas pas me virer quoi
ça avait été dit avant la rendre qu'ils
allaient faire ça bon pendant sans rien
mais dans tous les cas pendant la partie
et ben ils ont voulu en fait qu'il soit
au courant et tout peu importe c'est pas
aussi et pour moi ce qui ce qui est
juste absolument incroyable c'est que tu
peux pas
enfin il y a plein de tables
il y a plein de tables en fait pour
jouer pourquoi tu prends la table du mec
qui joue quoi enfin tu vois et ça par
contre c'est une faute d'organisation
quoi c'est pas normal tu vois moi je
change de hypnot qui était mal au temps
et il est gagnant et tu vas lui prendre
ça à table pour
s'arrêter prévu mais ok mais c'est une
faute d'organisation de base tu peux pas
prévoir un truc comme ça
parce que enfin pour moi c'est une faute
regarde clairement parce que prévoir un
truc ou ben tu sais que quoi qu'il
arrive s'il y a un départage et bien je
vais te virer de ta place pendant
diagnost juste c'est pas normal donc
c'est quand même un tournoi qui dure
deux semaines
tu as cette heure par jour à un moment
donné les
erreurs comme ça enfin les tu peux tu
peux t'organiser un peu mieux pour pour
essayer d'éviter tu vois
franchement si tu fais
non mais
déjà
moi je m'en fous que tu bouges ma table
alors en fin de partie et que moi je
suis pas à 45 je suis pas fait rouge etc
mais regarde un tournoi qui dure deux
semaines 7h par jour toujours échecs
franchement me dit pas que tu as pas
tant ton créneau de 2 semaines à un
moment donné où tu peux trouver
un endroit où juste même une heure pour
faire un départage tranquille sans que
personne sans gêner personne
ça tu vois c'est pas la faute de férozen
c'est pas ça habiter à lui de sortir
pour laisser place aux deux qui veulent
faire leur Death Note eux aussi je leur
tournoi eux aussi ils ont le droit
d'avoir les mêmes conditions que tous
ceux qui jouent le tournoi quoi moi je
veux un tournoi je suis désolé mais me
bouger pendant la partie pour laisser la
place un mec qui a fait un départage moi
ça me fait chier je te dis clairement
moi ça me rendrait fou mais c'est pas
une minute pour bouger c'est pas ça
c'est juste que c'est c'est pas
respectueux je trouve que c'est pas
respectueux le mec il a 2800 hello il
joue son tournoi il a invité pour faire
un tournoi prestigieux comme ça TOI tu
peux venir me dire tiens vas-y pose-toi
un peu je vais faire un avantage sur ta
table ben pour moi c'est une faute
d'orgas depuis le début ça a été prévu
répéter répéter peu importe je m'en fous
juste c'est pas cool pour moi c'est pas
normal de prévoir que le démontage sera
fait sur une table du tournoi et que
j'ai pas fini à temps et ben on va me
bouger je trouve que c'est pas normal
pour moi c'est une faille du tournoi tu
peux pas si c'est toi du coin le temps
du coin un Open de je sais pas
tata win les Bains etc je suis d'accord
que oui bah les mecs sont pas pro etc là
c'est un tournoi hyper pro hyper
prestigieux avec Carlson avec je sais
pas combien de milliers d'euros en prix
etc bah faire un tour dans un sérieux
quoi pour moi c'est juste pas normal de
prendre la place d'un joueur
qui est en train de jouer il retient
vas-y pousse-toi un peu je vais faire un
départage pendant que tu joues quoi je
trouve que c'est pas normal c'est tout
donc après
il y a eu aussi le fait que ben oui
il y a eu bon il était en diagnotte en
plus il a pas gagné la partie qui était
gagnante en plus donc ça c'est aussi
d'ailleurs peut-être que si il avait
déjà terminé la partie ou s'il était
perdant ou si bon ça aurait pu être
différent et dans tous les cas dans tous
les cas moi je trouve que ça se fait pas
c'est une faille de leur gars qui qui va
pas en fait
mettre un départage en plein milieu du
tournoi et surtout sur
sur la table d'un joueur en direct tu
vois et que ce soit fil rouge Jacques
Carlsen ou Kemar je m'en fous en fait
juste ça c'est pas chaque joueur est là
même si même si tu me prends la table de
l'openb même si tu me prends la dernière
étape de PNB tu vois et tu me dis tiens
les gars dégager un peu on va mettre
Carlson ben non enfin en fait non enfin
les mecs sont là ils font le tournoi ils
ont trois tu jouais leur tournoi
pourquoi tu vas me virer ça a été prévu
depuis le début mais je dis pas que ces
problèmes pour moi le problème c'est que
ces mecs là en fait l'organisation
aurait pas dû faire ça à l'origine pour
moi c'est une faille
pour moi c'est un problème
d'organisation ils auraient pas dû faire
comme ça après que en plus il y a eu la
partie qui a pas été gagnée etc c'est
une excuse peut-être ou pas sans n'en
sais rien mais à l'origine la faute
c'est l'orgas et ça j'en suis enfin pour
moi c'est mon avis on peut débattre si
tu veux mais chacun après à ce qu'on a
vu mais pour moi c'est juste pas normal
de faire ça
je crois qu'on a fâché
parce qu'en fait pour moi c'est c'est
évident quoi
pendant la ronde ok tu as raison
pourquoi pas
[Musique]
comment
mais en fait tu peux prévoir avant le
tournoi à faire tout ça etc et faire ce
que tu veux parce que au final bah c'est
toi la regarde c'est toi qui décide mais
au final au final
que la face pendant le tournoi pourquoi
pas par contre que tu dises que on va
prendre la table
x d'un joueur qui est en train de jouer
même si tu l'annonce avant pour moi
c'est pas normal ça veut dire que tu
sais que si un des partages et ben
peu importe comment enfin ce qui se
passe sur ton échiquier mais en gros je
vais te prendre ta table je la décaler
je vais faire je veux quelqu'un contre
la place pour faire un match de
départage je suis désolé ben non enfin
je suis en train de jouer tu me laisse
finir la partie où tu prends notre table
mais je trouve que pendant la partie
c'est un temps la prestigieux il y a
beaucoup il y a beaucoup d'enjeux
beaucoup de prix à la gagne les mecs
sont concentrés tu vois le simple fait
de venir me voir arrêter la pendule me
faire déménager me faire me lever
marcher qui me pose pendant la partie et
ben en fait je peux perdre ma
concentration et juste il était quoi
c'est juste normal quoi et après c'est
pas pour ça qu'il a blunters lui il dit
que c'est la faute de l'orga
férosex et qu'il a pas gagné à cause de
ça peut-être oui peut-être non on n'en
sait rien dans tous les cas tu as pas à
déranger un joueur qui est en train de
jouer juste enfin pour ça pour moi c'est
c'est faute de jeu pour moi c'est x donc
en fait même si c'est prévu avant pour
moi c'est une erreur de base de
l'organisation
tu peux pas me dire qu'en deux semaines
de tournoi elle est tout le temps que tu
as une heure près à la fin quoi tu vois
juste fini le tournoi que les parties
soit fini après tu fais des partages par
exemple tu vois moi je ferai ça
comment j'avais des avions à prendre non
mais ok mais bon ben tu es une joie de
repos de moins et puis et puis tu enfin
je sais pas mais
tu vois ce qui va dire toi deux semaines
à 7h par jour tu dis ben je sais pas
où tu l'as commence une heure avant
enfin j'en sais rien mais en fait non
mais il y a des solutions on est
d'accord que on n'a pas envie d'y être
et on a pas envie que quelqu'un
comme n'importe quel autre
perturbation oui effectivement c'est pas
normal c'est encore une fois c'est même
pas c'est même pas vraiment le le
problème de vola ronde enfin de jeux de
partage pendant la ronde c'est même pas
dans le problème moi mon vrai problème à
moi c'est de prendre mon échec donc je
suis en train de jouer ça ça me rend fou
moi je suis là j'ai le droit de jouer
enfin c'est ma table et je suis en deck
note tu peux pas me déranger pour ça en
fait je trouve juste je trouve juste que
c'est c'est pas c'est
pas correct
c'est pas correct de la part des organes
même si ça va être ça avant pour moi
l'organisation de base
a fait ça c'était un problème de budget
vous avez pas non mais c'est une blague
ça
moi je rigole ah mais oui tu vois ce que
je veux dire en fait dans l'idée c'est
c'est
pour moi c'est juste c'est juste
scandaleux ce qui s'est passé
mais après son après ce sont ils se sont
exclusés auprès de Buffy
mais il faut déjà pas accepté les
excuses bon ça encore une fois c'est
c'est autre chose tu vois je pense que
l'erreur est humaine ok c'est pas grave
c'est la vie on peut en parler et puis
voilà et puis tu peux accepter tu vois
furosa il est un peu
tu vois il prend un peu trop perso mais
en vrai parce que bon après je sais pas
critiquer les choix de chacun c'est
parce que mais dans l'idée
je peux faire une erreur et puis la vie
continue enfin c'est pas grave ça tu
vois on passe quoi on passe à autre
chose mais
n'empêche que de base l'erreur c'est de
l'organe tu peux pas avoir un tournoi
aussi prestigieux prendre la place de
quelqu'un qui est en train de jouer quoi
juste c'est pas normal
c'est juste pas normal
je me suis un peu fâché je crois
non mais c'est vrai
parce que non mais il y a des gens qui
en fait le simple fait de dire que oui
ben il dit que c'est la faute de l'orga
peut-être que il peut dire ça et
peut-être que c'est vrai c'est pas vrai
mais de base tu as pas le droit de faire
ça tu as pas le droit de me changer de
table enfin en fait c'est juste pas
le fait vraiment d'être jeune mais le
fait que ce soit la première fois ou une
des premières fois que quelque chose
t'arrive bah tu te prends plus mal alors
si tu as l'habitude tu finis par
relativiser mais je pense que c'est
aussi ça l'espèce de froid c'est que
c'est la
sûrement la première fois qu'il avait à
faire quelque chose comme ça et du coup
il est resté il a un gros caractère et
c'est clair il y a eu il y a eu d'autres
cas où ben tu vois il aime pas perdre
etc je comprends et il y a une faute de
la part de l'organe qui aurait pas dû
faire ça ça se voyait enfin c'était pas
cool
après qu'il ait perdu c'est pas
forcément la faute de l'orga mais mais
c'est clair qu'il y a une faute de base
de la regarde
donc du coup voilà mais non mais après
peut-être que dans quelques années il va
dire banquer c'est bon enfin ça va tu
vois on s'en fout
next tu vois et je vais le tournoi tu
vois c'est pas un souci mais juste tu
peux pas me virer parce que quelqu'un de
plus important vient quoi même si
c'était prévu de base je pense quand
même le tournoi avec le nombre de
centaines de joueurs qu'il y a au
tournoi tu manques pas de table tu
manques pas de chaise tu manques pas de
végéter tu manques pas enfin juste
si tu veux éviter les problèmes il y a
des solutions quand même donc voilà
c'est juste ça que je dis donc firou
peut-être tu exagères un petit peu
dans toutes ces histoires mais
faut pas oublier que de base
les fautifs c'est quoi
et en vrai moi je pense que à sa place
j'aurais peut-être qu'il franchement
j'aurais été aussi
j'aurais dit mais juste enfin non quoi
enfin non
je refuse quoi
non mais tu vois je paye ma place tu
vois je paye mon je suis comme tout le
monde toi tu vois juste
mais voilà après oui bah peut-être ça
arrive à Ding il va rien dire Ding
parce que c'est dingue
mais ça rien à carcasser je vais vous
dire Carsen il va il va dire mais enfin
qu'est-ce que tu fais quoi enfin
tu vois après ça peut arriver à
n'importe qui même à rognan il va
quitter enfin tout le monde en fait
c'est normal même Carona il va dilté
veut dire attends enfin c'est pas normal
c'est normal c'est est-ce que toi tu
aurais tilté
appelle-moi appelle-moi ça va se régler
vite fait
pendant une partie
je pense que c'est déjà arrivé à
d'autres personnes du chat aussi
mais j'ai pas dit
du monde et puis nous c'est différent et
puis les les enjeux sont quand même
différents tu vois
et puis ça dépend de quel moment de la
partie toujours ou tu vois moi ça m'est
arrivé un open j'avais le soleil dans la
gueule bah juste je peux pas jouer quoi
je suis ébloui juste on va changer on va
changer de place tu vois mais c'est pas
un tournoi avec des budgets de plusieurs
centaines de milliers d'euros
enfin juste pour moi en fait le niveau
d'organisation du tournoi est tellement
élevé que tu peux pas faire ça c'est
juste ça en fait parce que tu fais un
tournoi voilà chez toi dans dans ta
Bretagne
ou n'importe quel endroit maintenant de
club tranquille tu vois juste bah oui il
y a des conditions bizarres oui on fait
non mais ce que je veux dire en fait
c'est que chacun fait comme Marion du
bord mais quand tu as un tournoi avec
plusieurs centaines de milliers d'euros
de prix juste les choses bien quoi
enfin c'est juste ça en fait que je peux
pas comprendre que tu peux tu peux pas
faire un truc comme ça si enfin tu vois
[Musique]
jamais comme ça mais on me l'a déjà fait
par rapport au soleil ou je ne sais quoi
il faut aller changer les tables bon
c'est pas
le supporter par contre la triche
là parce que là je peux être un câble
ah oui c'est pas grave d'accord c'est
pas correct
surtout franchement c'est une partie
avec enjeu quoi parti avec un jeu
je sais pas bon mais là on est d'accord
que le niveau l'organisation c'est
exagéré et puis non mais oui vu le
niveau de l'organisation tu peux pas
faire ça c'est une grosse grosse faute
si tu veux le tournoi de de
d'un petit patelin ben oui enfin en fait
ce qu'on peut et là il y a pas de souci
tu vois
là moi je sais plus ce qu'il a fait roux
dans le tournoi quelle place il jouait
mais à chaque palier de prix il y a
peut-être 10000 euros de d'écart
enfin la partie si la gagne peut-être
qu'il gagne beaucoup plus d'argent enfin
tu vois
il pensait revenir un premier execo
quelque chose comme ça mais avec le
départage c'était pas possible sauf que
l'huile de savait pas non mais peu
importe si lui il peut l'être ou pas
l'être on s'en fout mais dans l'idée il
y a il y a beaucoup d'argent en jeu
l'organisation elle est elle est elle
est hyper hyper bien
donc juste ça fait quoi ça fait tâche
dans une dans un style retournant en
fait
oui c'est un petit patelin mais leur
gars elle est monstrueuse
je sais plus mais dans tous les cas
que tu le fasses pendant la ronde bon
c'est une chose mais que tu prennes sa
table alors qu'il en decnote et qui
enfin non juste
c'est un truc que je pourrais la faire
quoi
comme il y avait le Championnat du Monde
championnat du monde
c'était l'année dernière champion du
monde de partir rapide et Blitz ils
étaient plusieurs
execos pour jouer des partages ils ont
pris que Abdou et
nepo alors qu'il y avait aussi 45 qui
était là il y avait aussi d'autres gens
qui n'ont pas pu participer au match de
départage parce qu'il connaît que les
deux premiers pour le match de partage
ce qui est complètement débile
je prends pas deux quoi mais bon
qu'est-ce que tu veux
mais
[Musique]
oui enfin juste
voilà bref donc du coup moi je me serais
fâché en fait ça dépend encore une fois
si on joue trois coups et qu'on a changé
je m'en fous ça implique pas ça va pas
changer ma partie
mais là je prends un techno je joue un
gros enjeu je suis hyper concentré tu
vas pas me déranger quoi
c'est juste ça
[Musique]
[Rires]
c'est magnifique si c'est pas du troll
c'est encore plus beau
et du coup tu regarderas le replay dans
tous les cas
[Rires]
[Musique]
c'est
on peut dire merci on peut lui dire
merci de faire durer autant le plaisir
pour avoir de si belles discussions
et du coup Milo attend son résumé c'est
tout non
s'il y a un moyen que les Blancs
craquent je pense pas moi je fais échec
mais en fait moi qui passe
attends quand même
un moyen de passer
je pense à ça pour faire ça
[Musique]
c'est pas forcément le meilleur coup
le Minecraft tu peux essayer de faire un
petit truc mais bon
c'est un peu du mal à croire quand même
40 minutes chacun avec avec
15 minutes de rajout dans 10 coups ils
sont bien
moi je pensais pas autant m'amuser on
vient ici
j'avoue que je suis pas déçu
c'est pas si simple
si seulement
sa chaîne Youtube
on la chauffe pour
Twitter on la chauffe pour se lancer
mais elle veut pas
et du coup
en plus apparemment mon micro fonctionne
mal et les gens n'avaient pas prévenu et
toi non plus
j'ai une voix
en direct
je la ressors
dans la casserole quoi
c'est plus simple
comment vas-tu
les gars si vous connaissez pas
je vous fais un petit saut vers sa
chaîne il stream pas trop des échecs
mais il est il est hyper hyper sympa
franchement
il est très drôle je vous envoie vers sa
chaîne si vous voulez vous amuser c'est
quasiment tous les soirs jusqu'à très
tard je voudrais avoir sa chaîne
allez le voir faites-lui un gros bisou
on peut faire comme ça pour chaque
personne
que le prochain qui parle après route il
a son pseudo vert
moi je te barrer qui sera orange
cordialement
[Musique]
nous aussi en stream d'ailleurs enfin
moi non mais moi je stream aussi un
petit
saut vers ma chaîne alors je bon là ça
fait vraiment que j'ai pas trop stream
vu que merci pour ce pour ce
saut enfin tout donc je stream moi aussi
sur ma chaîne mais du coup là avec tous
les événements cheescom bah j'ai pas
trop trop eu le temps d'en avoir de
streamer mais je vous promets en tout
cas de revenir très bientôt mais du coup
on a vraiment si vous voulez
[Musique]
venir ce que je fais en stream et bien
vous avez le lien sur le chat vous avez
aussi Youtube je suis stouf échec pour
aussi me retrouver sur Youtube je suis
un peu nouveau pour le coup sur Youtube
mais venez me voir en tout cas
et puis de l'Orient en direct ouais
c'est ça on pourra chanter
en direct
peut être sympa
streamer exceptionnel franchement
vous avez pu le comprendre
il commence à
mais on recommande
bien
en ce moment
très
gagner grâce à
j'espère que tu vas bien
te voir
donc du coup je disais que oui donc je
stream etc sur YouTube sur twitch je
vais y arriver donc n'hésitez pas en
tout cas à venir nous voir
quand on sera en ligne
chez moi les rouges non chez moi les
vertes
on n'a pas le même enfin moi aussi vert
mais
ça dépend ça dépend parfois
à ce qu'elle a la douche
je suis à la douche mais je vous regarde
quel est le génie quoi
Lorie alors je sais plus il faut que tu
me fasses une petite
moi je me souviens plus les chansons
je veux juste qu'on rappelle c'était
quoi le pari si le pseudo était orange
est pas vert mais t'inquiète pas je vais
bientôt hein
je te dois
Dieu tous les comptes
depuis le début
trois verres sans préciser quoi de Layon
[Musique]
c'est parce que c'est exactement
et on sauve le jour où je lance ma
chaîne
je suis pas sûr de
les Noirs passent en fait ils vont faire
ça
ça peut-être changer une tour et de
passer pas simplement
non mais
[Musique]
mais je prendrai jamais une cuite au un
truc sucré
ça c'est le
la jauge dit que oui bon là je dis que
ça peut tenir mais après c'est compliqué
un prix et puis en plus
[Musique]
elle peut se tromper
qui fait tout le temps la fermeture quoi
tous les jours il fait la fermeture
je pense que les sièges doivent vraiment
être hyper
[Musique]
confortable parce que là c'est pas
possible
tous les jours
le pilier
ou
il est en train de pousser pousser
pousser il n'a pas gagné une encore
chaque
je crois qu'à chaque fin de stream que
j'ai vu c'était lui
[Musique]
contreding lui contre Abdou la lutte
contre contre
il a joué qui encore je peux te dire
[Musique]
je sais plus ce que c'était la partie
qu'on parle
non ça a fini on relativement rapidement
quand carène il l'a fini vide contre
Prague
il me semble qu'il a
ah oui ils ont fait nul mais il était
ils ont joué pendant très longtemps ça
dans la partie il a failli perdre contre
un Gazi
non c'était normal
qui perd c'était la lui la fin dans la
partie ça fait deux fois qu'il fait dans
la partie
contre sa
W c'était aussi une finale qui a duré
longtemps c'était je crois une des
dernières parties aussi ça fait trois
dignes 4
[Musique]
contre guéri non pas tant que ça
à 12,5 ouais donc sur 5 parties ça fait
6 sur 10 et ben l'an dernier quoi c'est
ouf quand même
dans le tournoi
et c'est lui qui fait la fermeture à
chaque fois franchement niveau énergie
[Musique]
c'est ouf
salut le contre le contrat je sais pas
comment tu veux qu'on t'appelle
bonsoir amis si tu veux être mon ami
bonsoir à tous en tout cas tous ceux qui
sont sur le stream ce qui viennent
d'arriver
tous les leurkers
c'est un mec qui a un problème de table
qu'on a besoin
c'est un peu de c'est un peu de la
provocation ça un peu je crois qu'il a
envie que je rembobine
pour un robinet
pourquoi dit c'est déjà trop oui
[Musique]
je pense dans
du coup
pour empêcher toi parce que pour ça que
je prends là et ça et là par contre là
ça va faire
mais du coup
[Musique]
maintenant qu'est-ce que je fais
peut-être ça
pourquoi la barre
[Applaudissements]
le petit parapluie tu sais comme on l'a
fait non non OK
je comprends pas pourquoi la
courbe elle monte tout en haut
j'ai compris
c'est bon je pense qu'à partir de ce
moment l'industrie je prends le relais
je te laisse te reposer mentalement
j'aimerais bien
on va faire des couleurs des flèches
j'ai pas la main là
mon adversaire ne joue pas et va avoir
de l'automatiquement le grand maître
m'attend
ça
content de voir que tu as passé les mecs
que tu as passé les 400 os
par un là-bas ou pas forfait
parce que
[Musique]
Vincent Kemer et ben il est parti se
promener il a droit en fait quand c'est
pas ton tour de jouer ben tu peux
clairement en fait te lever te promener
et par conservatoire de jouer ben tu
reviens t'asseoir quoi
et merci pour tout merci pour le seum